Die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, die Bielefeld-Werke, Fritz.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, wir haben den 29. Oktober 5 nach 10. Das heißt Zeit fürs Chaos Radio auf Fritz und den Chaos Computer Club und ich begrüße herzlichst Constanze. Guten Abend. Und ich begrüße noch, noch herzlicher oder aufs genauso herzlichste natürlich nicht, dass es jetzt zur Missstimmung kommt. Ey, die Falle da auf der Staule, das ist bös, Constanze. Nein, Frank Rosengardt, guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Da sind wir wieder. Wir haben heute ein wunderbares Thema für euch, nämlich die fast schon traditionell jährliche Sendung über die Förderung der Big Brother Awards dieses Jahr 2008. Die Unternehmen und Firmen und Menschen in unserem Land, die sich darüber verdient gemacht haben, die meisten Daten zu sammeln, den wenigsten Leuten Bescheid zu sagen und damit die Daten-Azis Nummer eins sind.
Die Daten-Azis ist schick.
Die Daten-Kraken sind.
Die Daten-Kraken, die Daten-Azis, also die Leute, die mit euren Daten Schindluder treiben, die werden wir euch vorstellen. Frank war nämlich in der Jury vom Big Brother Award 2008 und kann eine Menge Dinge darüber erzählen, wie es so abgelaufen ist und wie sich auch die beschenkten oder verehrten in diesem Jahr verhalten haben. Denn es war sogar jemand da, aus der ausgerechten Mal.
Es war jemand da, das erzählen wir aber nachher. Das macht es ein bisschen spannend. Und von euch wollen wir heute Abend auch wissen, wer sind eure persönlichen Favoriten. Also ihr habt die Möglichkeit heute Abend auch Firmen, Institutionen, Politiker zu nominieren, von denen ihr glaubt, die hätten aber auf jeden Fall einen Preis bekommen müssen.
Irgendjemand, der eure Daten eingesammelt hat, von denen ihr glaubt, das geht die doch eigentlich gar nichts an. 0331 ist die Potsdamer Vorwahl, 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer, unter der ihr uns erreichen könnt. Ihr könnt auch gerne im Netz mitmachen. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Grundseite, auf die ihr gehen solltet. Und den Rest werdet ihr dann schon finden. Ihr seid ja alles clevere Kerlchen und clevere Kerlchinnen. Bevor wir aber zum Big Brother Award kommen, müssen wir ganz kurz natürlich das Thema Wahlcomputer noch ansprechen. In dieser Woche ging die mündliche Verhandlung der Klage vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht los.
Ach, so könnte man sagen. Es ist eigentlich eine Anhörung und keine Klage, sondern eine Beschwerde.
Die Hoffnung geht ja immer nicht, geht ja erst zuletzt.
Ja, naja, die Juristen haben halt ihre eigenen Termine für so Veranstaltungen. Wir haben eigentlich zwei Gründe, über Wahlcomputer zu sprechen. Zum einen haben wir am Montag einen Bericht öffentlich gemacht, noch von der Wahlbeobachtung in Brandenburg. Das heißt, wir haben einfach zusammengestellt, was unsere freiwilligen Wahlbeobachter so gesehen haben. Und daraus ist doch ein 42-seitiges Dokument geworden.
Da gab es ja, wir haben auch Fritz auch darüber berichtet und kurz Interview gemacht, da gab es ja die absurdesten Geschichten von Wahlcomputern, die vor dem Abend der Wahl in irgendeinem Privathaushalt aufgehoben wurden und gelagert wurden.
Keiner weiß, was da passiert ist.
In Brandenburg war es ein bisschen anders, aber durchaus vergleichbar wie Hessen. Auch hier haben wir halt beobachtet, dass die Wahlcomputer durchaus schon mal an den Wochenenden in Kindergärten und Schulen gelagert wurden. Wir haben auch wieder gesehen, dass zum Beispiel die Siegel und die Plomben nicht so richtig geprüft wurden. Und vor allen Dingen haben wir eine neue Art von Problemen festgestellt hier in Brandenburg. Nämlich, dass es sehr, sehr große Benutzungsschwierigkeiten gab. Ich meine, wer selber wählen war hier in Brandenburg, wird es ja gesehen haben, es gab ja bei diesen Kommunalen waren echt viele Vorschläge. Es war alles so recht kompliziert, noch mit der Kreiswahl und so oft. Und so hat diese Tastenfeld auf dem Wahlcomputer von der Größe her einfach nicht ausgereicht, sodass die Schrift so winzig war, dass sie Lupen an die Wahlcomputer gelegt haben, damit man überhaupt lesen konnte. Und so haben natürlich die Wähler da irgendwie minutenlang hinter dem Sichtschutz verbracht und entsprechend haben sich da bis zu 50 Minuten lange Schlangen gebildet.
Das heißt, es kann durchaus passieren, dass Leute wählen wollten, ihre Stimme abgeben wollten und dann so lange warten mussten, bis sie sagten, ich muss jetzt aber zur Arbeit oder sonst wo hin und so viel Zeit habe ich nicht. Das heißt, an der Ausübung ihres Wahlrechts mehr oder weniger gehindert wurden.
Und es gibt halt dokumentierte Fälle, die wir auch zusammengetragen haben. Und es ist natürlich unerhört, dass also auch nach jetzt mehreren Jahren, wo ja die Wahlcomputer im Einsatz sind, immer noch solche Fehler passieren und dass vor allem die offiziell immer noch behaupten, dass alles rosig wäre mit diesen Wahlcomputern.
Und die Kritik an den Wahlcomputern gibt es schon ganz lange, du hast es gerade erwähnt, sie werden ja auch bei den nächsten Wahlen mit ziemlicher Sicherheit immer wieder mal auf den Tisch kommen.
Das ist halt die Frage, denn gestern war ja die Anhörung.
Deswegen ist diese Geschichte vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht umso interessanter, wie denn die Richter jetzt entscheiden, ob sie sagen, benutzt sie weiter oder ob sie sagen, das ist bedenklich.
Ja, der Chaos Computer Club hatte ja dort technisch Stellung genommen. Denn im Gericht hat uns ja gefragt, ob wir dokumentieren könnten, wie dieser sogenannte NEDAP-Pack, denn die Wahlcomputer heißen NEDAPs, also der Hersteller heißt NEDAP. Und das haben wir getan, das war ja schon im Mai. Und wir haben uns eigentlich über die Anhörung gestern sehr gefreut, über eine ein bisschen größere Delikation da. Wir wollten natürlich auch mal hören, ob da die Fragen sind von den Richtern. Und es war schon nicht unwichtig, dass diese Manipulationsmöglichkeiten jetzt bewiesen sind. Aber viel wichtiger war glaube ich die Frage nach der Transparenz und Nachvollziehbarkeit, weil es gibt ja keinen Papierbeleg mehr. Man muss einfach nur vertrauen, dass eben das richtige Ergebnis rauskommt. Und da haben die Richter schon die richtigen Fragen gestellt und eigentlich sich sehr skeptisch gezeigt. War auch sehr spannend und teilweise auch sehr lustig. Man wird durchaus auch schon mal gelächter im Publikum, weil vor allen Dingen der hessische Landeswahlleiter, Herr Wolfgang Hannabell, sich da doch einigermaßen blambiert hat. Weil manche Aussagen waren halt einfach komisch und zwar nicht absichtlich komisch, aber so, dass das Publikum ganz gut gedacht hat.
Wie ist denn jetzt die Tendenz zu sehen? Also es gab jetzt eine Anhörung, die Mühlen der Büros malen langsam. Über welchen Zeitraum sprechen wir jetzt, bis es eine Entscheidung gibt?
Na, da gibt es schon gesetzliche Grundlagen dafür. Die Richter haben jetzt quasi maximal drei Monate. Das heißt, Anfang des Jahres würde die Urteil zu erwarten sein, vielleicht sogar schon früher. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass sie den Bericht, den wir abgegeben haben, jetzt zur Brandenburg-Wahl noch wahrnehmen und wir gehen noch davon aus, dass sie ihn bereits gelesen haben. Also wir hoffen, dass auch die praktischen Probleme, die wir in den Wahlbeobachtungen gesehen haben, dann noch einfließen. Und diese rosernen Bilder, die ja immer von den Verantwortlichen nah an die Wand gemalt werden, so nicht durchgehen. Also wir hoffen schon, dass zumindest die NEDAP-Wahlcomputer, so wie sie jetzt zugelassen sind, danach nicht mehr eingesetzt werden dürfen. Da hoffen wir schon drauf.
Also spätestens im Januar, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen früher, gibt es eine Entscheidung darüber. Entweder unter ccc.de oder aber hier in dieser kleinen Familiensendung immer am Mittwochabend oder auf Fritz. Selbstverständlich halten wir euch auf den laufenden, was das Thema Wahlcomputer denn angeht. Müssen wir darüber noch irgendwelche Worte verlieren oder wollen wir jetzt zu dem?
Na vielleicht kann man noch sagen, dass wenn man jetzt auf ccc.de klickt, da steht der Bericht, wer den gerne mal lesen möchte, der ist auch durchaus unterhaltsam und bebildert. Wir haben jetzt schon viel Feedback bekommen, dass es durchaus Spaß macht, den zu lesen.
Werden ja auch jetzt lange kalte und dunkle Winternächte.
Genau.
Kann man sich sowas mal neben die T-Taste stellen. Okay, jetzt machen wir eine kleine dramaturgische Technik-Trick. Und zwar, wenn wir jetzt ein Stückchen Musik spielen, um eine thematische Trennung der beiden Themen hinzukriegen. Hieße auch ganz kurz und fabulös, kommt aus Schweden. Und danach reden wir mit euch gemeinsam über die Verleihung der Big Brother Awards 2008 und Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz. The Horror, The Horror Country City im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Der Chaos Computer Club hat heute wieder hier die Mikrofone und die Antenne übernommen. Konz und Frank sind da und wir reden über den Big Brother Award 2008. Bevor wir zum Einzelnen zu den Preisträgern kommen, muss Frank uns noch mal einen Einblick geben in diesen Ablauf der ganzen Veranstaltung. Ist das so eine, naja wie bei Popstars würde es ja nicht aussehen, aber so eine Schulaula, wo so Tische stehen vorne mit so einer weißen Decke drauf, dann sitzen wichtige Menschen und der Rest sitzt unten, schreibt eifrig mit oder wie läuft sowas?
Also wir versuchen das schon wie so eine Art Gala zu machen, dass das Ganze so ein bisschen einen festlichen Rahmen hat und auch so eine gewisse Seriosität zu haben. Es gibt ein Rahmenprogramm. Das ist also in einem Saal, in einem öffentlichen Gebäude in Bielefeld von der Volkshochschule oben. Also schon ein recht schöner Saal auch. Da gehen ungefähr 400 Leute rein. 450 waren ungefähr da, schätze ich mal. Also standen immer noch so ein paar Leute daneben.
Also es war knackevoll.
Es war richtig voll wieder. Es ist irgendwie auf einen Freitag Abend. Das heißt, da kommen Leute einfach auch gern. Es gibt ein bisschen Musik, es gibt irgendwie so eine kleine Band, die zwischendurch spielt, ein bisschen auflockert. Wir hatten dieses Mal da einen Zauberer, der auch, ja nicht Datenschutztricks, aber schon ein paar Tricks gemacht hat, den ganzen ein bisschen so thematisch angepasst hat. Der eure Daten verschwinden lässt. Mit so einem Hütchenspiel, hier sind ihre Daten, sind sie da, sind sie weg, sind sie woanders. Und jetzt habe ich sie hinten aus der Jacke gezaubert. Also so ein bisschen diese ganzen Sachen ein bisschen aufgelockert hat. Das war ganz schön. Und es gibt einen professionellen Moderator, der auch durch das Programm führt. Und dann ist es eigentlich immer im Wechsel. Es gibt noch mal Quizspielchen, Ratespielchen zwischendrin, Schätzspiele und ja, zwischendrin sind dann die Laudatoren, die oder Laudatorinnen, die die Laudatio vorlesen, die also einen Preisträger vorstellen. Und im Anschluss wird dann auch mal gefragt. Und gibt es jemand, der den Preis abholen will? Also ist es tatsächlich auch ein verkörperter Preis, einen Pokal, eine Figur, die wir haben, die dann auch erreicht werden kann. Bisher war nur einmal, ich glaube das Lügen, das war vor fünf oder vor sechs Jahren, war die Firma Microsoft da, die den Preis abgeholt hat. Das war eine ziemlich gute Leistung. Und auch dieses Jahr ist tatsächlich jemand gekommen und hat diesen Preis entgegengenommen. Wir hören jetzt aber erstmal, wer das war und um was es ging.
Meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, der Big Brother Award 2008 in der Kategorie Arbeitswelt und Kommunikation geht an die Deutsche Telekom AG für die... Für nicht wirklich überraschend die illegale Nutzung von Telefonverbindungsdaten zur Bespitzelung von Telekom Aufsichtsräten und Journalisten. Die Deutsche Telekom AG hat sich damit vorsätzlich gleich über mehrere Gesetze hinweggesetzt und damit dem Vertrauen in das Telekommunikationsgeheimnis, die Pressefreiheit und den Datenschutz einen empfindlichen und möglicherweise bleibenden Schaden zugefügt. Die Rechtsverletzungen lassen sich nüchtern aufzählen. Der Konzern hat sich intern an Daten vergriffen, deren Verwendung zu Ermittlungszwecken ansonsten nur mit richterlichen Beschluss möglich ist. Mehrere hunderttausend Telefon- und Mobilfunkdatensätze von eigenen Aufsichtsräten und Journalisten wurden illegal ausgewertet, um herauszufinden, auf welchem Wege vertrauliche Informationen an Medien gelangt waren.
Na, da kann man doch schon mal einen Preis verleihen für die großartige Leistung.
Genau, das war Friedrich Rogan, der war der Laudator für diesen Preisträger. Und, ja, oh Wunder, die Telekom hat tatsächlich jemand geschickt. Herr Ulm, das ist der Konzern Datenschutzbeauftragte. Allerdings jetzt nicht der neue Datenschutzvorstand, der Beils, der jetzt einberufen wurde, sondern eher der Formale, der also wirklich für die organisatorischen Abläufe bei der Telekom zuständig ist. Der war da sichlich zerknirscht und auch ein bisschen aufgeregt und hat aber trotzdem gesagt, sie nehmen es sehr dankbar. Natürlich ist es blöd, dass sie den Preis bekommen, aber sie können es schon verstehen und fanden es in Nachhinein auch natürlich zu Recht und haben auch gesagt, dass sie es wichtig finden, dass es diesen Preis gibt. Dann muss man mal schauen, ob das einerseits ein bisschen Blabla ist. Andererseits ist derjenige wirklich, er ist einfach Datenschützer, in dem Sinne als dass der Konzern Datenschutzbeauftragte ist. Eigentlich ist es auch sein Job, diese Daten wirklich zu schützen. Er hat natürlich ein bisschen die blöde Position, dass er da auch bei diesen ganzen Skandalen, die es in der letzten Zeit gab, auch dann gar nicht mehr so viel machen konnte, weil dies dann irgendwie passiert. Und das ist glaube ich auch nichts, was jetzt an Details rauskommt, wo er wirklich, sag ich mal, wo ihm was vorzuwerfen ist, wo er noch irgendwas hätte verhindern können. Insofern war es auch ein bisschen unglückliche Personen, die sie da geschickt haben.
Aber sie haben überhaupt jemanden geschickt?
Aber es war jemand da und es ist auch vom Publikum absolut anerkannt worden. Es gab einen riesen Applaus, dass jemand da war. Und die Telekom nimmt dieses Problem jetzt öffentlich auch wahr und nimmt diesen Preis auch an und zeigt damit ja auch ein bisschen was.
Heute kam gerade die Meldung, dass aufgrund dieses Skandals zwar die ersten Mitarbeiter als auch Aufsichtsratsmitglieder ihren Hut nehmen.
Oder so.
Zumindest geht es in die Richtung, was Frank gerade sagte, sie nehmen den Preis an und versuchen sich in der Öffentlichkeit dessen zu stellen. Sollen wir ganz kurz vielleicht noch mal erklären, was da überhaupt passiert ist und was das möglicherweise mit dir, mir, uns und euch am Radio zu tun hat?
Ja, also der Datenskandal bei der Telekom ist ziemlich vielfältig. Es ist ja nicht nur ein Skandal, sondern eigentlich eine ganze Skandalkette. Wobei man auch sagen muss, dass natürlich die Aufmerksamkeit der Öffentlichkeit denn auch besonders sensibilisiert ist, wenn einmal so ein Skandal hochkommt. Das melden sich dann Informanten, das wird nachrecherchiert, die Journalisten graben auch noch mal Geschichten aus, was ja auch richtig ist. Und deswegen kam es jetzt wirklich auch alles so kompakt raus. Und was noch viel schlimmer ist, das ist eigentlich jetzt wie so ein Never Ending Story, weil nämlich kam jetzt gerade kürzlich, ich glaube gestern oder vorgestern ans Licht, dass also die eine Datenschutzverletzung wurde versucht, mit einer weiteren Datenschutzverletzung aufzudecken. Das heißt also, um rauszukriegen, wer diese Daten weitergegeben hat, hat man auch wieder illegal auf Daten zurückgegriffen im Unternehmen. Und das ist natürlich dann eine ganz blöde Sache, vor allem, wenn man gerade paar Tage vorher den Big Brother Award bekommen hat und auch hochenheilig versprochen hat, dass man sich besser wird, dass sowas nie wieder vorkommen wird. Ja, also es sind einfach Telefondaten ausgewertet worden. Es ist so, dass Journalisten kriegen bei T-Mobile einen ordentlichen Rabatt. Die kriegen also eine Karte, eine Handykarte zu einem sehr guten Tarif. Hat natürlich den kleinen Haken, dass T-Mobile dann auch weiß, dass es Journalisten sind. Was es dann auch einfach macht, da mal entsprechend in den Daten zu suchen. Es ist so, dass die Daten natürlich alle schon für Rechnungszwecke aufgehoben werden. Das heißt also, wer wann von wo mit wem telefoniert. Dazu möglicherweise noch interne Kommunikationen. Die Telekom hat als Unternehmen auch Zugriff auf alle E-Mails. Sie kann auch die Daten der Telefonanlage auswerten. Es ist also schon ein ganz erhebliche Datenberg, der da anfällt. Und es macht bestimmt Spaß, sage ich mal in Anführungszeichen, da drin zu stöbern und ist in solchen Fällen bestimmt auch effektiv. Und ja, dabei hat sich die Telekom erwischen lassen.
Das heißt, die Telekom hat ihre eigene kleine Vorratsdatenspeicherung benutzt?
Genau, die haben im Prinzip ja eigentlich was mit Geheimdienstmethoden, sogenanntes Data Mining betroffen. Das heißt, sie haben durchgeführt und haben speziell auch eine Firma, das macht sie noch mal ein bisschen schärfer, haben also eine externe Firma beauftragt und gesagt, hier sind irgendwie von dem fraglichen Zeitraum die interessanten Datensätze, sucht uns doch mal da was interessantes raus. So vereinfacht gesagt.
Ich glaube, das größere Problem, dass es eben die Telekom ist und das Skandal so großfördig zum einen daran, dass natürlich immer noch sehr, sehr viele Deutsche bei der Telekom sind, dass es eben immer noch der größte Telekommunikationsprovider ist. Aber ich glaube auch, die Sachen, die danach kamen, haben diesen Spitze-Skandal, wie er am Anfang ja hieß, noch verstärkt. Denn man muss auch sehen, dass die Telekom halt ein paar Wochen später ihre komplette Datenbank mit allen Kundendaten verloren hat. Also bei 30 Millionen durfte so ungefähr die Anzahl der Kunden sein, die die haben. Zwischendurch noch dieser kleine Callcenter-Skandal, wo also klar war, dass auch die die Daten, die sie so über ihre Kunden haben für Callcenter-Beratung oder Akquise, dass die also noch weitergeben, wie er händert ist als so ein Konglomerat. Und man muss sich ja immer sagen, dass immer nur ein Teil der Datenskandale ans Licht kommt. Man möchte gar nicht wissen, was die Technikster intern noch erzählen. Wenn man mit jemandem ins Gespräch kommt, dann möchte man sich nachher betrinken.
Gibt es eigentlich bei der ganzen Verleihung der Big Brother Awards, die ja jedes Jahr stattfinden, und die Sensibilität für Datenschutz und auch Schutz der Privatsphäre wird ja theoretisch jede Woche, jeden Monat größer mit jedem Kanal. Gab es da irgendwie auch Anmerkungen zum Thema Datenklau bei den Banken, was ja dieses Jahr auch ganz groß war, dass über Telekommunikationsunternehmen und auch über Banken und über Lotteriefirmen plötzlich auf wie Millionen Kontodaten von Bundesbürgern weg waren und verkauft wurden?
Nee, da haben wir jetzt mit Absicht keinen Preis gegeben, weil es dann natürlich auch schwierig ist, einen klaren Preisträger für zu finden. Und wir versuchen natürlich auch vor allem eher systematische Sachen aufzudecken, anstatt jetzt in Anführungszeichen bedauerliche Einzelfälle. Also wenn jetzt mal irgendwie eine Firma irgendwie ihre Kundendatenbank ausgesehen im Netz, dann ist das halt irgendwie ärgerlich, aber in Regel keine systematische Sache. Bei der Telekom ist das was anderes. Das war jetzt der vorletzte Skandal, wo sie also, das muss man sagen, es war T-Mobile, wo also speziell für die externen Shops oder irgendwelche Vertriebspunkte, dass sie sich per Internet einloggen konnten, alle irgendwie gleich mit dem gleichen Passwort ohne besonderen Schutz und konnten bei eben alle Kundendaten abrufen. Das ist natürlich das Thema. Also das ist einfach ein ganz klares Versäumnis. Das darf so nicht sein. Aber wenn jetzt eine Firma irgendwie mal ihre Sachen im Netz hatte, irgendwie kurz, dann ist es der Schaden für die Firma meistens schon so groß. Da muss man dann nicht noch nachlegen. So, das haben die dann auch schon begriffen.
Also der der Fakt ist, dass Datenhandel des Kommerziellen war schon so nicht auf dem Tablett.
Eigentlich geht es fast immer um irgendwie Datenhandel mit irgendwelchen Sachen. Also wir haben ja auch mindestens noch einen Preisträger, wo es auch wieder um eine gewisse Art von Datenhandel geht. Aber den Datenhandel als solches muss man auch mal sehr differenzieren. Also es gibt dann einerseits mal den legalen, dann so diesen grau Bereich und diesen absolut illegalen Datenhandel. Und da muss man immer sehr genau schauen, wer ist denn schuld oder kreidet man jetzt denjenigen an, der die Daten gekauft hat und verwendet hat? Oder ist es derjenige, der die Daten weitergegeben hat? Was vielleicht sogar legal war, weil die Kunden das Einverständnis gegeben haben. Möglicherweise nicht ganz bewusst, aber sie haben es zumindestens auf dem Papier. Das heißt also, sie hat legal völlig okay gehandelt. Also wir versuchen da auch immer schon sehr hip und stichfestern zu sein, bei unseren Begründungen bei den Preisträgern. Vielleicht mal ein ganz kurzer Exkurs. Das ist so, dass wir im Laufe des Jahres dazu aufrufen, dass die Leute uns Vorschläge schicken, dass die Leute also sagen, okay, das wäre jetzt hier irgendwie mein Preisträger oder ich habe hier das und das erlebt, und was haltet ihr da und davon? Das wird dann gesammelt. Im August sitzt dann das Team vom FöBoot in Bielefeld. Das ist also auch ein befreundeter Verein, der sich für Verbraucherschutz, Datenschutz, Privatsphäre einsetzt, der die Big Brother Award ausrichtet jetzt seit ein paar Jahren, oder seit vielen Jahren seit es sie in Deutschland gibt. Die sitzen dann da ganz fleißig, sammeln die Sachen zusammen, machen dann ein paar dicke Ordner auf Papier. Das kriegt dann die Jury. Die Jurymitglieder bekommen es zugeschickt. Dann haben wir ungefähr drei Wochen Zeit, das durchzugehen, mal zu gucken, anzukreuzen, welche sind unsere Favoriten. Wer glauben wir, wer interessanter Preisträger ist. Dann machen wir ein bisschen Recherche, gucken schon mal nach, haben vielleicht noch ein paar Rückfragen an die Leute, die eine Adresse angegeben haben. Es gibt auch viele anonyme Einsendungen, teilweise auch aus sehr gutem Grund. Das respektieren wir natürlich. Nur, da können wir dann nicht nachfragen. Das hat dann den Haken. Aber meistens ergibt sich das, dass wir eine Information noch nachschlagen können. Dann haben wir eine große Jury-Sitzung. Da werden dann auch schon die fast, oder eigentlich die finalen Kandidaten festgelegt. Das heißt, da sitzen wir den ganzen Tag zusammen, überlegen, okay, der ist preiswürdig, der ist vielleicht nicht so interessant, der hatte schon letztes Jahr und ach nicht, noch mal eine Kundenkarte. Das wird ja langweilig. Wir haben da eigentlich auch schon ein bisschen so eine traurige Routine teilweise, wo andere Leute vielleicht sagen, um Gottes Willen, das ist ja aber nicht schon wieder so eine Kundenkarte. Ja und dann entstehen daraus die Preisträger und dann geht es darum, dass wir vier Wochen Zeit haben, ungefähr nochmal eine tiefgründige Recherche zu machen, nochmal alles doppelt und dreifach zu checken und entsprechend Laudatio vorzubereiten.
Dieses Jahr unter den Preisträgern ist zum Beispiel eine Krankenkasse, ist ein großer Stromanbieter, sind natürlich auch Mitglieder aus der Politik, auch das EU-Parlament ist unter anderem dabei. Falls ihr jetzt das Gefühl habt, da ist irgendwas noch nicht so an die große Glocke gehängt worden, wie ihr es gerne hättet, falls ihr erlebt habt, dass irgendjemand mit euren Daten Unsinn gemacht hat oder ihr einfach auch ein Big Brother Award verleihen möchtet, dann sei diese Sendung auch eure. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0331 70 97 1S 0 oder euch im Netz einklicken unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Damit verbunden wäre natürlich auch die Frage, ob sich im Laufe der letzten Jahre eure Sensibilität für Daten und für Privatsphäre und so weiter und so fort verändert hat, weil die Datenskandale, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, Bankenskandal und auch den Datenklau bei der Telekom, über den wir gerade gesprochen haben, sich immer mehr erholfen, weil das Interesse auch größer daran ist und es kommen immer mehr diese Fälle ans Licht, ob ihr dann in irgendeiner Form skeptisch seid, vorsichtig seid und wie ihr euch dazu verhaltet. Darüber können wir gerne reden in dieser Sendung 0331 70 97 1S 0. Ich würde ganz kurz nochmal, bevor wir eine Musik spielen, ganz kurz nochmal den Vergleich zum letzten Jahr ziehen wollen. Da waren ja wunderbare Sachen dabei, wie die Hotelkette Marriott zum Beispiel, die die Daten von ihren Kunden ausgewertet hat für weitere betriebliche Veranstaltungen. Also die haben ausgewertet, hast du eine Allergie, brauchst du also eine spezielle Bettwäsche, wann hast du eingecheckt, wann hast du ausgecheckt, mit wem hast du kommuniziert, welches Essen, welches Trinken hast du, hast du Beschwerden, welche Fernsehkanäle hast du geguckt und das wurde alles aufgeschrieben, mit welcher Kritikkarte hast du bezahlt, konntest du überhaupt zahlen und das wurde dann ausgewertet, ohne dass die Leute gefragt wurden. Schöne Spannerei, die waren letztes Jahr glaube ich der absolute Publikumsfavorit.
Das war einer der Favoriten auf jeden Fall, wobei man muss ja sagen, ich meine, die meinen es ja nur gut du, die hotels, das ist ja alles natürlich zum Kundenservice, das geht ja nicht um den Kunden auszuforschen, sondern es geht darum, einen besonders guten Service zu haben, dass man nicht jede Sachen wieder in einzelne abfragen muss und dann schon gleich weiß, braucht vielleicht ein hartes Kissen oder braucht irgendwie ein besonderes Essen oder so was. Kann man sich überstreiten. Es gibt auf jeden Fall viele Leute, die das nicht so cool fanden und gab es noch entsprechendes Echo. Wir haben davon auch was mitbekommen. Es gab, also mal, eher von einer menschlichen Ebene war eine Sache, die auch sehr wichtig war. Das war die Frage, ob in Hamburg nicht Migranten, sondern ob Leute, die illegal leben, die also keinen ordentlichen Aufenthaltsstatus haben, wenn die ihre Kinder zur Schule schicken, dass das gemeldet werden soll.
Damit die Stadt Hamburg gleich mal Übersicht hat, wie viele Leute unangemeldet in ihrer Stadt wohnen.
Genau. Das hat natürlich offiziell eine andere Begründung, aber der Nebeneffekt wäre dann, dass die Eltern die Kinder eben nicht zur Schule schicken, weil sie Angst haben, dann entsprechend ausgewiesen zu werden oder abgeschoben zu werden.
Das waren so Preisträger aus dem letzten Jahr. Dieses Jahr sind auch viele wunderbare Exemplare dabei. Wir werden gleich mehr davon heimlich. Freue mich jetzt schon, solange aber noch passende Musik aus Berlin. Border Party, Anti-Anti, dann die Nachrichten, dann geht's weiter am Chaos Radio mit dem Big Brother Awards 2008.
Fritz bietet euch jetzt die einmalige Gelegenheit, in ungefähr drei Jahren sagen zu können.
Black Kids im Olympiastadion?
Pff, die hab ich schon vor ungefähr drei Jahren im Lido gesehen.
Das ist doch geil. Fritz präsentiert Black Kids. Black Kids kommen den Dienstag im Lido. Berlin Kreuzberg. Karten gibt's überall wo es Karten gibt und mehr Infos. Beste neue Musik von jetzt und live.
Und das hört man.
3 nach halb 11.
Der Zeitplan für die Berliner Umweltzone soll eingehalten werden. Darauf besteht Umweltsenatorin Lomscha von der Linken trotz Kritik. Danach dürfen ab 2010 Fahrzeuge mit roter und gelber Plakette nicht mehr in die Innenstadt fahren. Die Grünen stehen hinter dem Termin, fordern aber Kredite zum Umrüsten alter Fahrzeuge. Die CDU und Teile der SPD verlangen eine Verschiebung der Pläne um zwei Jahre. Im sogenannten Kofferbomberprozess in Düsseldorf hat die Bundesanwaltschaft eine lebenslange Haftstrafe für den Angeklagten gefordert. Ihm wird vielfacher Versuch der Mord vorgeworfen. Der 24-jährige Libanese wird beschuldigt, mit einem Komplizen im Kölner Hauptbahnhof selbstgebaute Bomben in zwei Zügen deponiert zu haben. Die Bomben seien wegen eines handwerklichen Fehlers nicht explodiert. Der Komplize war in den Libanon geflohen und bekam dort zwölf Jahre Gefängnis. Im Osten der Demokratischen Republik Kongo wird die Lage immer dramatischer. Rebellen sind in die Provinzhauptstadt Goma eingedrungen, plündern Häuser und kämpfen mit Regierungstruppen. Die Stadt war zuletzt noch das Ziel zehntausender Flüchtlinge gewesen, die sich vor den Kämpfen im Umland in Sicherheit bringen wollten. Im Ostkongo kämpfen verschiedene Rebellentruppen aus Nachbarländern, seit Jahren um die an Bodenschätzen reichen Gebiete. Befeuert wird der Konflikt durch das Geld ausländischer Konzerne. China hat die USA als größten Produzenten von Treibhausgasen eingeholt. Das geht aus dem Weißbuch zum Klimaschutz davor, das die Regierung in Peking heute vorlegte. Danach haben die Emissionen der Volksrepublik inzwischen das amerikanische Niveau erreicht. Die USA produzieren jährlich rund 1, 5 Milliarden Tonnen CO2. Experten befürchten, dass der Ausstoß von Kohlenstoffdioxid in China durch das rasche Wirtschaftswachstum weiter stark zunehmen wird. In der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Hertha BSC am Abend gegen Hannover mit 3 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Berliner stehen nach diesem Sieg mit 18 Punkten auf dem 5. Tabellenplatz. Spitzenreiter ist wieder Aufsteiger Hoffenheim nach einem 3 zu 1 Erfolg in Bochum. Die weiteren Ergebnisse Frankfurt verliert gegen Bayern München 1 zu 2, Köln unterliegt Dortmund 0 zu 1 und Hamburg besiegt Stuttgart 2 zu 0. Die Eisbären Berlin haben ihr zweites Champions League Spiel beim russischen Pokalverteidiger Metalurg Magnitor Gorsk 2 zu 5 verloren. Damit kann der deutsche Eishockey-Meister nur noch theoretisch das Halbfinale erreichen. Der Abend ist und bleibt stark bewirkt in Berlin und Brandenburg. Nachts kann es vor allem im Südosten kräftig regnen, morgen bleibt es stark bewirkt, regnerisch, es kann auch Schnee regnen, am Nachmittag soll es aber ein bisschen auflockern. Kühl wird's morgen mit Temperaturen zwischen 3 und maximal 7 Grad. Aktuell sind es in Frankfurt 6 Grad, in Berlin Angermünde und Potsdam 5 Grad, in Neuropin und Cottbus 4 und in Wittenberge gar nur 1 Grad. A10 östlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Sprayau. Zwischen Rüdersdorf und Erkner gibt es Behinderungen durch einen kaputten Laster im Baustellenbereich. A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berliner Ring. Zwischen den Ausfahrten Brandenburg an der Havel und Netzen ist wegen Bauarbeiten der rechten Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111 statt auswärts. Berlin Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg. Zwischen dem Dreieck Charlottenburg und Heckerdamm ist wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten die linke Spur gesperrt. A113 statt auswärts. Berlin Neukölln Richtung Schönefeld. Zwischen Spätsstraße und Stubenrauchstraße ist die linke und ist auch die mittlere Spur gesperrt. Und wegen Wartungsarbeiten kommt es heute Nacht auch zu Spursperrungen auf dem Stadtring. Der A100, bitte achtet auf die Beschilderungen und passt eure Fahrweise an. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und bei einem Radio 91, 9? Dann fritz rund um Bälzig.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Zeit fürs Chaos Radio auf Fritz heute. Jetzt hab ich die laufende Nummer gar nicht im Kopf. Ich würde sagen, wir sind bei 140, oder?
Ja.
Ja, stimmt das?
Ich kann es nicht bestätigen, aber auch nicht erratieren.
Ist uns, glaube ich, relativ wumpe heute, weil es geht um...
Wir fragen einfach den Hörer, der muss es sagen.
Hörer, rufe an, sage uns bitte welche, aber ich glaube wir sind bei 140.
Wir nehmen den Hörer, den wir hier schon haben.
Ja, nee, auf jeden Fall, ich will es ja ganz kurz sagen. Also Chaos Computer Club ist hier. Frank Rosengardt und Constanze und wir reden über die Big Brother Awards 2008. Letztes Jahr hat Bundesfinanzminister Pierre Steinbrück einbekommen für die glorreiche Einführung einer lebenslangen Steueridentifikationsnummer, die wir jetzt alle haben. Und dazu haben wir gleich mal eine Frage, und zwar von Oliver aus Berlin. Namens.
Ja, ich bin relativ spontan reingekommen ins Radio und hatte diese Frage. Vielleicht kommt es auch nicht ganz zum Thema. Bitte um Entschuldigung, falls es ein bisschen abweicht. Ich habe, wie alle, vor ein paar Wochen ja dieses Steueridentnummer per Post bekommen. Und dieser Brief, der in meinem Briefkasten lag, der war offen. Und ich habe dann also reingeguckt und habe dann dieses Steueridentnummer gesehen und die Daten, die scheinbar zu dieser Schlüsselnummer hinterlegt sind. Also Nachname, halt Geburtsdatum.
War der Brief so offen, wie offensichtlich aufgerissen oder wie zufällig irgendwo hängen geblieben?
Nee, es war wirklich wie, wenn jemand den aufgemacht hat. Aufgemacht, rausgenommen, wieder reingelegt. Ich vermute erstmal nichts Schlimmes. Ich denke mal, der Briefträger hat es vielleicht falsch eingeworfen. Und der andere Nachbar hat es gesehen und merkt, oh ist gar nicht für mich und hat es richtig reingeworfen. Das könnte vielleicht der harmlose Fall sein. Was mich jetzt eigentlich nur bewegt bei der Frage ist, was kann jemand tun, der sozusagen die hinterlegten Schlüsselsätze zu dieser Nummer kennen würde? Gibt es da irgendwelche Missbrauchsansätze, die ich da haben kann?
Oder die du jetzt befürchten musst?
Na ja, momentan noch nicht, da wir ja ohnehin empfehlen, dass du dir von der humanistischen Union diese Widerspruchsschreiben holst und dahinschickst. Also noch brauchst du da nicht viel befürchten. In einem Jahr sieht es schon ein bisschen anders aus.
Lass mal ganz kurz noch mal auf dieses Widerspruchsschreiben eingehen.
Na die humanistische Union hat auf ihrer Webseite gerne vorformuliert Schreiben, wo man, was man als Formular quasi benutzen kann, um ein Widerspruch zu machen. Zwar hat diese Schreiben keine Widerspruchsbelehrung, wie normalerweise bei amtlichen Schreiben, wenn sie ein Bescheid sind dabei ist, dennoch kann man einfach sagen, ne will ich nicht und einen Brief schicken. Nicht wirklich viel, das hat so eine Form von aufschiebender Wirkung, aber da die humanistische Union auch ein Musterverfahren führt, mal sein Protest in eine Form von zivilem Widerstand.
Aber die Frage von Oliver noch mal weitergedacht, also könnte er jetzt bei seinem zuständigen Finanzamt anrufen, sagen der Brief war offen, das Geheimnis ist verletzt, ich hätte gerne eine andere Nummer.
Ich habe ihn sogar befahren.
Wie, du hast ihn geschrieben und hast gesagt...
Nein, in diesem Schreiben ist so eine Info-Hotline drin gewesen. Dann habe ich einfach mal angerufen und habe dem Typen, wahrscheinlich auch ein Callcenter, die da früher beauftragt wurden, keine Ahnung, die Sachlage geschildert, dem auch meine Besorgnis geäußert und eigentlich gesagt, ich will das eigentlich nicht, ich möchte gerne eine neue Nummer haben. Wenn es schon nicht anders gehen sollte. Also wenn eine Nummer dann bitte nochmal erneut und bitte so zu stellen, dass es nicht geöffnet wurde. Und das wurde abgelehnt, hat den Motto, das kann man nicht tun. Und die Nummer ist jetzt da und hast Pech gehabt so ungefähr.
Na ja nun, die ist dir zugewiesen, zu sagen, ab dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem du lebst, in dem Fall jetzt erst ab jetzt, weil der jetzt anfängt, bis über dein Tod hinaus, bis über 20 Jahre, den Tod hinaus, den werden sie nicht auf Antrag ändern. Dann würde ja auch diese eine nötige Nummer ihren Sinn verlieren. Wenn jeder kommt, der sagt, oh, jemand hat meine Steuer-ID erfahren, ich möchte jetzt eine neue. Das ist dann natürlich nicht so schön für so ein Personenkennzeichen. Und dass die beim Kosten natürlich da irgendwie gar nichts machen können, ist ja nicht weiter überraschend.
Also jetzt muss man auch sagen, das Problem ist, glaube ich, auch tatsächlich nicht die Nummer als solche, sondern wahrscheinlich machst du dir eher Sorgen wegen der Information, die da sonst so drin ist. Da stand ja auch noch mal eine ganze Menge anderes drin in dem Schreiben.
Also bei mir waren halt eben die normalen Datensätze, Anschrift, Geburtsdatum, Nachname, Vorname.
Genau, das ist ja schon mal eine ganze Menge. Also wenn es um geht, irgendwo, weiß nicht, was online zu bestellen, vielleicht ein Konto eröffnen, braucht man schon noch einen Nachweis für. Aber es gibt ja schon noch ein paar Sachen, wo die Daten abgefragt werden. Und das ist das große Problem beim sogenannten Identitätsdiebstahl. Das ist zum Glück in Deutschland noch nicht so ein riesiges, massenhaftes Problem. Aber es ist natürlich schon immer ein bisschen ungutes Gefühl, wenn du weißt, dass jemand vielleicht auch aus deinem Haus, der ja auch unter der eine Anschrift erreichbar ist, dann möglicherweise unter deinem Namen irgendwelche Sachen bestellen könnte. Also es ist schon nicht so ganz cool, dass da auch vor allem das Geburtsdatum drin steht.
Und dann hast du plötzlich eine Kiste Motorateile vor der Tür, die du gar nicht haben willst. Das kann ja auch passieren, wenn du die gar nicht verstehst. Okay, aber der optimistische Pessimist in mir könnte jetzt auch antworten, gut, dein Brief ist jetzt geöffnet, die Datensätze sind bekannt. Ob die jetzt bekannt werden oder ob die in einem halben Jahr wieder irgendwo geflamed werden, ist dann eigentlich auch egal.
Du wirst sie dann eh deinem Arbeitgeberkund tun müssen, der dann ja weiterverwendet. Also da wird wahrscheinlich wirst du eh nicht drum rumkommen, dass du dir bald einen Short machen kannst. Zur Demo hier in Berlin hatten ja schon viele ihre Steuer-ID auf dem Unterarm geschrieben, was ich ja ein bisschen makaber fand.
Sag mal, hast du denn...
Vielleicht einen letzten Satz dazu noch. Es ist, du hast, dieser Brief ist kein Bescheid. Denn ihm fehlt die Wiederrufsbelehrung. Das ist im Prinzip nur ein Brief. Du kannst auch sagen, du hast ihn nie erhalten.
Ja, und dann ist die Nummer nicht für mich existent. Doch, die ist ja existent.
Sie werden ja einfach neun schicken wahrscheinlich.
Ähm, richtig. Also wenn ich jetzt der Arbeitgeber nach der Nummer frag, dann kannst du sagen, ich hab keinen bekommen. Irgendwann werden sie natürlich dazu übergehen, dir einen zuzustellen. Dann hast du halt bekommen.
Aber es wäre die gleiche Nummer mit den gleichen Sätzen hinterlegt.
Richtig, das wird dieselbe Nummer sein.
Abgesehen von der Steuernummer-Geschichte hast du da noch irgendwie einen Kandidaten, einen Preisträger, vielleicht nicht der neugierige Nachbar gerade, der irgendwie deine Steuernummer erschnüffeln wollte oder der Briefträger, wer auch immer es war.
Ja, das ist ja das Thema eurer Sendung gewesen.
Genau.
Ja, da hab ich leider keine Anekdote zu.
Na, kannst du uns dann vielleicht sagen, welche Nummer dieses Chaosradio hat?
Sind wir mit 140 richtig? Macht überhaupt nichts. Kriegen wir schon noch raus. Aber Herr Steinbrück hat ja auch schon tatsächlich, hat ja Jakob auch schon gesagt, wir haben im letzten Jahr dem einen Big Brother Award gegeben. Der Big Brother Award wird immer in mehreren Kategorien vergeben. So ist auch eine Kategorie letztes Jahr an ihn gegangen für die Einführung der SteuerID, Steueridentifikationsnummer selbst schon relativ alt ist. Auch sogar so alt ist, dass man schon mittlerweile eigentlich gar nicht mehr dagegen klagen kann so richtig. Also zumindest nicht gegen die Einführung, nur gegen die konkrete Zuteilung. Das ist jetzt auch das, was jetzt läuft. Aber immerhin SteuerID war auch schon einer unserer Preisträger.
Hat eigentlich der Kollege Steinbrück, der ja diesen Big Brother Award bekommen hat, hat er den in irgendeiner Form zugestellt bekommen? Also steht er bei ihm im Arbeitszimmer auf dem Kamin oder so?
Nee, also vielleicht auch noch ein kurzes Wort zum Prozedere. Das läuft so ab, dass wir rechtzeitig vor der Preisverleihung die entsprechenden Behörden, Firmen informieren. Das heißt, wir schreiben also an die Geschäftsleitung oder an den zuständigen, höchsten Menschen in der Abteilung oder in dem Ministerium, in der Behörde. Wir informieren in der Regel auch noch den Konzern Datenschutzbeauftragten oder Firmendatenschutzbeauftragten und auch noch die PR-Abteilung. Das heißt also, die Firma kann sich wirklich nicht rausreden, dass sie irgendwie nicht davon gewusst hätten.
Gut, Oliver, vielen Dank. Letzte Frage an dich. Wie heißt ein Bär, der 8 Ecken hat?
Achteerbär.
Nee, hör zu. Tschüss, Olli.
Und das hört man.
Wir haben nur noch 2 Tage, um den zu spielen. Ich finde den super. Chaosradio auf Fritz, Teil 140 habe ich nachgeguckt. Am Telefon ist Christian, grüß dich. Hallo, auch bei dir geht es um die Steuernummer. Da haben wir ja doch wieder ins Schwarze getroffen.
Ich hab schon eine. Ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass das kein Bescheid wäre, weil da keine Rechtsbewerbbelehrung drunter ist. Das ist glaube ich nicht ganz so richtig, weil ein Bescheid ist das schon. Normalerweise hat man ja eine Widerspruchsfrist, das steht dann drin, was man da machen kann, und wenn das nicht drin steht, dann verlängert sich die Widerspruchsfrist einfach auf ein Jahr.
Das ist richtig.
Aber ein Bescheid ist es trotzdem, das kann man nicht einfach ignorieren.
Man kann es insofern ignorieren, dass man sagen kann, ich hab ihn schlecht nicht bekommen. Das kann man natürlich auch machen, wenn man Post vom Finanzamt bekommt, aber du hast natürlich recht damit, verlängert sich im Prinzip nur die Frist auf ein Jahr.
Wobei es aber auch einhaken muss, es ist unter Juristen umstritten, was es tatsächlich ist.
Aber weißt du, wir sind ja auch Hacker und keine Juristen, wir können uns ja immer rausreden mit Wir sind leiden.
Nein, ist ja auch okay, nur die Sache ist die. Ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, man hat den Brief nicht bekommen, das sind ja alles Einschreiben irgendwie. Also das ist kein normaler Brief, sondern das ist ein...
Bei Oliver gerade war es ein normaler Brief. Ich hab einen normalen Brief bekommen.
Ich hab sogar zwei normale Briefe.
Das war kein Einschreiben und kein Nix.
Also es ist ja so, die haben ja nun an die gesamte Bundesrepublik diese Nummern verschickt. Die haben ohnehin Probleme mit einer Million zurückgekommenen Briefe, weil die Datenteile nicht aktuell waren. Es ist jetzt erstmal nicht zu erwarten, dass sie da große Aktionen starten. Das ist ein sehr kleines Amt, was eben diese Verteilung der Steuer-IDs macht. Die sind jetzt eh gerade mal ausgelastet mit den Briefen, die sowieso zurückkommen mit den ganzen Leuten, die den Einspruch von der humanistischen Union auch noch schicken, weil sie eben diese Steuer-ID nicht wollen. Die sind jetzt eh gut ausgelastet und werden wahrscheinlich...
Das ist nicht das Bundesverwaltungsamt?
Ja, richtig.
Ah, das sind auch die, die die Abhörzentrale, die die zentrale Telefonabhörzentrale in Deutschland werden sollten. Das sind irgendwie die Deletanten, die da grad irgendwie die... Das hast du gesagt. Das sag ich genau. Aber wenn ihr euch den Brief anguckt, die sehen aus wie irgendwie in den 80er Jahren mit irgendeinem rottigen Nadeldrucker ausgedruckt. Also das ist schon sehr abenteuerlich, was da irgendwie kommt.
Ich finde auch, dass sie nicht mal eine Ansprache haben, ist nur sehr geehrter Herr, sehr geehrte Dame, ich weiß nicht mal, naja.
Aber was machen denn die, die die Steuer-ID quasi jetzt wegschmeißen? Ich meine, da wird es denen ja auch nicht geholfen. Also die kriegen dann irgendwann halt keine Ahnung.
Du wirfst sie ja nicht weg. Du sagst nur, sie hast sie weggeworfen oder so.
Wie auch immer.
Wir hatten Leute, die haben die Annahme verweigert. Also wie bei Werbebriefen, das klappt durchaus auch. Also die Strategien, sich dagegen zu werden, sind unterschiedlich, aber das wird dir natürlich nicht helfen.
Ich meine, was machst du, wenn dein Arbeitgeber dir sagt, gib mir deine Steueridee, sonst muss ich dir leider die höchste Steuerklasse abziehen.
Na bis Silvester, ist es dir noch okay, denn bis Silvester sollen die Briefe raus sein. Wenn dann der Arbeitgeber fragt, kannst du entweder nur ehrlicherweise oder unehrlicherweise sagen, hab ich noch nicht, aber du wirst sie nachreichen müssen. Dann wird entweder der Arbeitgeber fragen oder du musst selbst fragen. Wir können Glück haben, dass das Gerichtsverfahren zum Erfolg führt. Vielleicht haben wir ja über die Schiene Glück. Es gibt natürlich andere Formen. Man kann sagen, man lügt einfach bei der Nummer. Man baut da Zahlendreher ein. Das wird ja auch so passieren, Menschen. Aber so wird es wahrscheinlich relativ leicht gelöst. Denn die Finanzämter werden auch früher oder später die Nummern haben. Momentan noch nicht. Jeder hat ja jetzt auch eine Steuernummer, nur dass die eben nicht zentral vergeben wird und auch nicht unabänderlich ist. Aber es ist derzeit so, dass sich auch erst in den Finanzämtern dort die technischen, einfach die Systeme gerade erst ändern. Also die sind auch in so einem großen Umbruch. Das heißt, jetzt haben die Finanzämter noch nicht diese zentrale Nummer von dir.
Ich sehe, um mir kurz zu intervenieren, ich sehe das Thema Steuernummer ist nochmal ein sehr großes. Dazu lohnt es sich, nochmal eine extra Sendung zu machen. Wir kommen ein bisschen weg vom eigentlichen Anker der heutigen Sendung, der heißt Big Brother Awards. Christian, hast du noch eine Datenkrake für 2008 vorzuschlagen?
Datenkrake für 2008? Generell die ganzen Social Networks, aber die waren wahrscheinlich schon mal nominiert.
Nee, die waren noch nicht. Das ist auch interessant, wobei ich muss auch sagen, wir beschränken uns auch ausschließlich auf Firmen und Institutionen in Deutschland oder die zumindestens, also jetzt eine Ausnahme haben wir dieses Jahr mal gemacht, aber das ist auch der Grund, warum Google nicht jedes Jahr einen Preis bekommt, dass wir sagen, wir wollen eigentlich wirklich deutsche Firmen haben. Was denn? Ja, klar. Wobei wir aber auch immer beachten, dass gewisse Daten ja auch freiwillig sind. Man muss halt schauen, welche Sachen, wo ich als Kunde zum einen übers Ohr gehauen werde, d.h. wo mir versprochen wird, alles gut mit deinen Daten, kein Problem, und dann werden die hintenrum doch verkauft. Oder aber es ist eine Verpflichtung, d.h. dass der Staat sagt, du musst die und die Daten abgeben und dann passiert irgendwas damit. Entschuldigung, aber das ja wohl. Und das ist natürlich schon freiwillig auch. Ich mein, ich muss da nicht teilnehmen.
Bei Xing ist es ja so, auch so, dass du halt irgendwie, also klar, bist du verantwortlich, aber dass die halt ja doch alle nahe so lang die AGBs ändern und dann auf einmal hast du halt personalisierte Werbung auf deiner Seite, was vielleicht in dem Moment, wo du dich angemeldet hast, noch nicht so war. Oder wo die Daten dann möglicherweise...
Ja, ist schon richtig, aber personalisierte Werbung ist das eine. Die Big Brother Awards gehen ja dann noch ein kleines bisschen weiter. Um nochmal ein Beispiel als Vergleich aus dem letzten Jahr heranzuziehen, da gab es diese Planung- und Transportverkehr AG, die ein System entwickelt haben, das heißt Pay-as-you-drive, wo es ein Gerät in dein Auto eingebaut gab, das aufgezeichnet hat, wo du hingefahren bist und wie du fährst. Und das hast du an die Versicherung gemeldet. Und danach richtet sich deine Versicherungsprämie. Also es geht schon eher in diese Richtung als darum, dass du bei Google Mail oder bei StudiVZ oder bei wie sie alle heißen, Xing oder so bist und dann personalisierte Werbung bekommst. Was natürlich auch ASI ist, aber...
Ach jetzt hört doch mal auf, die zu verteidigen. Das ist aber mal gut. Die haben mal Entschuldigung.
Blöde, blöde, blöde Social Networks.
Jetzt hört doch mal auf, dann haben sie die AGB mehrfach geändert. Sie haben keinen Plan von Datensicherheit. Also die hätten es auch mal verdient. Jetzt verteidige ich die nicht noch.
Muss ich jetzt den MySpace-Song spielen? Nee, im Grunde des Wilds. Wir sagen erstmal Danke Christian und begrüßen gleich mal Max.
Ich wünsche dir einen tollen Vorschlag.
Hallo Max. Hier ist was los, oder? Ja, ich bin schon mal auf dem Weg nach Big Brother Awards 2008. Dein Vorschlag?
Web.de, schön, warum?
Genau, die wollen nämlich schon bei dieser Anmeldung für die E-Mail schon recht viele Daten von dir. Zum Beispiel Vornamen, Nachnamen, Straßhausnummer, Post-Aids, Ort, Land, Geburtsdatum.
Auch irgendwelche, weiß ich nicht, Vorlieben?
Nee, das wollen sie noch nicht.
Wobei diese ganzen personalisierten Daten oft gefordert werden, wenn du dir eine Mailadresse einrichtest, damit das zurückverfolgbar ist.
Hast du da die Wahrheit gesagt, oder hast du da leicht geflunkert? Das ist nur eine gute Möglichkeit.
Wobei, ich werde jetzt auch erstmal nicht in Schutz nehmen, aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass die diese Daten erheben, um vor allem auch personalisierte Werbung zu machen. Was jetzt eine Sache ist, die bei uns jetzt noch nicht unbedingt für den Preis reicht. Das wäre dann, wenn sie in ihren AGBs versprechen würden, alles wunderbar super und dann die Daten aber trotzdem verkloppen würden. Das wäre dann auf jeden Fall preisverdürftig.
Frank macht dir heute echt den Party-Pupa.
Ich würde sagen, wir kommen gleich mal zu einer neuen Kategorie. Ich würde gerne Kategorie Verbraucher machen mit dem Arbeitskreis Deutscher Markt- und Sozialforschung. Deutsche Markt- und Sozialforschungsinstitute.
Den Vorschlag von Max nehmen wir schon auf.
Auf jeden Fall, da kann man immer draufhauen.
Da hören wir jetzt die Karin Schuller, die nämlich genau für die Marktforschungsinstitute sprich Telefonumfragen, Telefonmarketing, Callcenter, den Preis verteilt hat.
Erstmal sagen wir alle Danke, Max und Tschüss.
Der Big Brother Award 2008 in der Kategorie Verbraucher geht an den Arbeitskreis Deutscher Markt- und Sozialforschungsinstitute EV ADM, vertreten durch seinen Vorsitzenden Herrn Hartmut Scheffler, stellvertretend auch für die Arbeitsgemeinschaft Sozialwissenschaftliche Institute EV, den Berufsverband Deutscher Markt- und Sozialforscher EV und die Deutschen Gesellschaft für Onlineforschung EV. Und zwar für die Empfehlung in einer Telefonrichtlinie, Telefoninterviews bei Bedarf ohne Kenntnis der Gesprächspartner heimlich mitzuhören und diese rechtswidrige Praxis auch nach Beanstandung durch die Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde weiterhin zu propagieren. Der ADM ist die Standesorganisation der größten und umsatzstärksten Markt- und Sozialforschungsinstitute. Dass das Mithören durch einen die Fachaufsicht führenden Kollegen möglich sein soll, kennt man allgemein aus dem Umfeld von Callcentern. Das, wie vom ADM empfohlen, dem externen Auftraggeber einer Befragung, dass Mithören ermöglicht werden soll, macht einen schon stutzig. Dass dies alles dann möglich sein soll, ohne Interviewer oder Befragten darüber zu informieren, geschweige denn deren Einverständnis einzuholen, macht einen schlichtweg sprachlos.
Das hat auf jeden Fall einen Preis verdient. Also noch mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Ich rufe irgendwo an, Callcenter für, keine Ahnung, Winterreifen und am Anfang kommt, wenn dieses Gespräch wird aus Qualitätsgründen mitgeschnitten, wenn Sie nicht wollen, sagen Sie bitte Autobahn.
Du sagst, ich möchte nicht, dass das Gespräch mitgeschnitten wird?
Jedes Mal. Und ich werde, ein Bekannter von mir...
Ich dreh das jetzt um.
Ne, warte mal, die Geschichte ist, ein Bekannter von mir, der arbeitet in einem Technik-Callcenter, die sozusagen auch Leute schulen, wenn du irgendwie ein Problem hast mit irgendeinem technischen Gerät, kannst du anrufen und sagen, hä? Und damit die Leute, die neu reinkommen, damit die geschult werden im Umgang mit Kunden, damit du möglichst schnell aufs Problem kommst, gibt es eben das, was die Frau eben auch gerade sagte, dass ein höher gestelltes Mitglied mithören kann. Die hören also das Gespräch mit und sagen dann danach, okay, die Frage anders formulieren, dann kommen wir einfach schneller zum Ziel und der Kunde ist ganz dicht und ganz schnell an seiner Lösung und muss nicht ewig rumdoktern. Sehe ich alles ein, kann auch jeder möglicherweise nachvollziehen, der mal in einem Callcenter angerufen hat und gesagt hat, mein Internet geht nicht. Und es ist aber meine eigene freie Wahl, vor dem eigentlichen Gespräch zu entscheiden, möchte ich es mitgeschnitten haben oder möchte ich es nicht? Ich sage immer, möchte ich nicht. Und der Freund von mir hat mir gesagt, wenn du sagst, möchtest du doch, machst du allgemein für die Qualitätssicherung besser, weil möglicherweise kann dir beim nächsten Mal schnell geholfen werden. Also ich kann da beide Seiten verstehen. Aber das, was hier passiert, dass ich sage, ich möchte es nicht und es würde trotzdem mitgeschnitten, das ist ASI.
Es geht dabei vor allem um Meinungsforschung. Das heißt, das sind auch sogenannte Outbound Calls. Das heißt, wenn mich jemand anruft, dann kommt nämlich diese Ansage in der Regel nicht. Sondern es ist dann einfach eine Umfrage. Und um die geht es dabei vor allem. Was aber ganz besonders pikant ist dabei, dass wir nämlich im letzten Jahr einen Preis vergeben haben an die Firma Novartis, die ja auch Umfragen gemacht hat unter der Belegschaft, wie dann so die allgemeine Stimmung ist. Eine Pharma-Firma. Ob der Arbeitsplatz denn gefällt, ob man an den Vorgesetzten was auszusetzen hat. Und es soll natürlich alles anonym sein. Und hinterher stellten die Arbeitnehmer dann fest, dass die Sachen dann so eins zu eins praktisch in ihrer Personalakte gelandet sind. Und unter diesem Aspekt ist es natürlich ganz besonders pikant, wenn man davon ausgehen muss, dass alles, was man am Telefon sagt und denkt, es ist ja eine anonyme Befragung und kriegt ja niemand mit. Und landet ja nur da im Computer. Und in Wirklichkeit werden dann offensichtlich diese Gespräche aufgezeichnet. Und dann möglicherweise sogar dem Auftraggeber, in dem Fall letztes Jahr eben der Arbeitgeber, auch vorgelegt.
Gab es da irgendwelche arbeitsrechtlichen, also personaltechnischen Konsequenzen? Wurde irgendjemand gefeuert deswegen oder so?
Nee, also im Gegenteil. Es wurde dann eher gefeuert gegen die Big Brother Awards und bzw. gegen den Verräter aus den eigenen Reihen. Was aber nur genau dieses Bild wieder bestätigt hat. Weil letztes Jahr war es eben auch so, dass der Preisträger oder der Preis auch für diese Einschüchterungsmaßnahmen vergeben wurde.
Und ich denke, das muss man auch immer wieder vortun. Ich finde das besonders wichtig, denn auch denjenigen, der in dem Unternehmen ist, der sogenannte Whistleblower, also der Preisgeber. Der Maulwurf. Genau, dass der auch geschützt wird und dass man versucht, ihm unter die Arme zu greifen und ihn zu stützen. Das finde ich ganz wichtig.
0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer vom Chaosradio auf Fritz. Ihr seid eingeladen, uns eure Vorschläge für Kandidaten des Big Brother Awards 2008 zu geben. Wir hatten die Telekom schon, wir hatten eben gerade den Arbeitskreis Deutscher Markt- und Sozialforschungsinstitute. Und der nächste Vorschlag kommt von Tobias. Guten Abend.
Was hast du dagegen Vodafone?
Vor allem erstmal so ein saftiges Ja. Jetzt muss ja was kommen.
Nee, das war so, ich hab ein Handyvertrag seit einer Weile bei Vodafone.
Oh, das ist aber erstmal schon mal dein Problem.
Glückwunsch.
Nee, das wäre nicht das Problem. Darum geht's ja nicht. Ich hatte zum Beispiel mal aus bestimmten Gründen meine Nummer ändern lassen.
Die jetzt hier nichts weiteres zur Sache tun, kommen wir zum Punkt, ja?
Also, ja.
Das ist nicht das Interessierte, klar.
Und nach vier Wochen hatte irgendjemand sich irgendwie bei 25 Ecken diese Nummer besorgt.
Okay, und hat was getan? Dich angerufen?
Und hat mich dann so ein bisschen geeigert. Weil jetzt hab ich die Nummer halt nochmal ändern lassen. Und mal gucken, wie lange es diesmal dauert.
Und du glaubst, dass Vodafone derjenige ist, der diese Nummer irgendwie geleakt hat? Also, wenn irgendjemand weitergegeben hat?
Ich denke, weitergegeben, also direkt weitergegeben denke ich mal nicht, aber ich denke mal, dass irgendwo Lücken sind, wie wenn...
Ah, du meinst, dass jemand darauf zugreifen konnte und das Vodafone zwar wusste, aber dass die schuld sind, weil sie keine richtige Datensicherheit haben.
Oder dass es vielleicht einen Insider gibt, der die Nummer rausgesucht hat, der Zugriff auf das Computersystem hat. Wäre ja auch denkbar, ist auch immer wieder mal ein Fall. Aber... Aber es kann vielleicht auch anders gewesen sein?
Ich bin möglicherweise jetzt zertrottel, ich hab's noch nicht ganz verstanden. Also du hattest eine Telefonnummer und hast dir dann eine neue geben lassen. Und hat dich dann auf der neuen oder auf der alten Nummer jemand angerufen?
Auf der neuen dann.
Auf der neuen Nummer. Aber du verteilst doch auch deine Telefonnummer, damit du mit Leuten telefonieren kannst. Du hast ja kein Telefonnummer.
Das Handy, das ich mit Wunder von hab, ist praktisch ein Handy, wo nur meine Mom die Telefonnummer hat.
Aber dass deine Mama möglicherweise einer Kollegin die Telefonnummer gegeben hat, weil sie sagt, wenn ich nicht telefonieren kann, rufst du meinen Sohn an?
Nee, das glaube ich eher nicht, weil sie generell keine Nummern weiter gibt.
Okay, das wollte ich jetzt einfach nur wissen, wenn du da ein Freundeskreis hast.
Nein, die Nummer hat von denen keiner. Aber de facto, de facto ist zwei Handys.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich.
Na gut, aber das ist natürlich auch ein, ja wie soll ich jetzt sagen, ziemlicher Einzelfall. Ich will jetzt ja auch nicht den Party Pooper machen, aber ich glaube, dass für so ein Big Brother Award reicht es glaube ich nicht. Wenn man natürlich strukturell nachweisen könnte.
Gibt ja noch ein Ding bei Vodafone. Seit ich den Vertrag bei denen habe, kriege ich regelmäßig auf meine angegebenen Rechnungsadresse Werbung von irgendwelchen Internet-Irotik-Versandhäusern zugeschickt.
Na, hast du vielleicht vergessen das Kreuzchen zu machen bei Ich bin nicht einverstanden, dass sie meine Daten nutzen?
Nee, ich habe ja den Vertrag direkt im Vodafone Shop gemacht. Und die Kreuzchen, ich habe mir jetzt noch mal eingeguckt, das Ding, die sind definitiv alle da.
Dann solltest du mal danach fragen bei den Leuten, die dir die Werbung schicken, wo sie denn deine Adresse haben. Also ich mache dir jetzt noch nicht allzu viel Hoffnung, dass du da ernsthaft irgendwie eine sinnvolle Antwort bekommst. Aber vielleicht kommt ja raus, dass die, keine Ahnung, eine Tochterfirma von Vodafone sind.
Also was ich machen würde, ist, ich würde erstmal so einen Standardbrief schreiben, den man sich bei den Landes- und beim Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten holen kann. Hier so einen Brief so, sagen sie mal bitte, ob sie meine Daten weitergegeben haben. Das würde ich zuerst machen. Das kostet ja irgendwie nichts. Darauf antworten, die oft in der Regel dauert nur ein bisschen. Das würde ich auf jeden Fall erstmal machen. Und dann mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Und wenn es alles nicht hilft, Telefon abschalten und umziehen.
Also wenn du mehr Fälle kennst als den einen, dann kannst du uns auch nochmal eine Mail droppen.
Also so ist es nicht. Also bei meinem Vater war es auch so gewesen, nachdem er den Wodafone-Vertrag gemacht hat. Bei ihm war das auch so.
Na ja, vielleicht qualifiziert sich hier gerade jemand für den Big Brother Award 2009. Wir haben das im Auge, schickt das einfach mal per Mail.
Na gut, dann hacken wir die übermorgen mal und gucken mal, ob das stimmt.
Danke Tobias.
Danke.
Schönen Abend. Also übrigens kurz nach 11. Eine Stunde rum und wir haben gerade mal zwei Preisträger für den Big Brother Award 2008 geschafft. Aber wir haben schon andere Vorschläge. Web.de, Vodafone, Mobilfunkanbieter ist allgemein höchstinteressant. StudiVZ hatten wir auch noch. Eure Vorschläge auch gerne unter 0331 70 97 110. Ich bin schon mal da. Aber der nächste Preisträger aus diesem Jahr ist wer, Frank?
Das ist die deutsche Angestelltenkrankenkasse. Eine Sache, wenn ihr ein bisschen die Medien verfolgt habt, ist es noch gar nicht so lange her. Und da hören wir jetzt Werner Hülsmann mit der Laudatio.
Der Big Brother Award 2008 in der Kategorie Gesundheit und Soziales geht an die deutsche Angestelltenkrankenkasse DRK, vertreten durch ihren Vorstandsvorsitzenden Herrn Prof. Dr. HC Herbert Rebscher. Für die unzulässige Weitergabe von Patientendaten 200.000 chronisch kranker Versicherter an eine Privatfirma, ohne die Versicherten über die Weitergabe zu informieren oder ihre Zustimmung einzuholen. Die DRK besteht nun laut Aussage ihres Leiters IT Services Dieter Schütt gegenüber Report Mainz darauf, es habe sich nicht um eine rechtswidrige Übermittlung personenbezogener Daten gehandelt, da Healthways die Daten im Rahmen einer sogenannten Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag erhalten habe und folglich datenschutzrechtlich betrachtet als gleiche Stelle gelte. Eine verbale Haarspalterei, denn die Gespräche, mit denen für die Teilnahme an dem Beratungsprogramm geworben wird, sind sicherlich keine reine Datenverarbeitung, sondern häufig sogar bereits mit einer medizinischen Beratung verbunden. Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Peter Schalis diese Ausrede deshalb auch nicht gelten. Für ihn geht es bei den Anrufen um die Beeinflussung des Verhaltens der Versicherten und nicht um eine automatisierte Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag. Daran wiederum stört sich die DRK nicht. Für sie sei der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte nicht die Instanz, die die DRK datenschutzrechtlich kritisieren dürfe.
Die Geschichte ist sehr kompliziert, beziehungsweise man muss also, es ist, okay, fangen wir von vorne an. Also es gibt sogenannte Chroniker-Programme, das sind besondere Programme der Krankenkassen. Wenn Leute da drin sind, weil sie chronisch krank sind, dann können die Krankenkassen aus einem bestimmten Topf Gelder beziehen, aus einem Umlagetopf der Krankenkassen.
In diesem Fall heißt das Programm Besser Leben.
Besser Leben, okay. Aber es hat was mit zu tun, dass chronisch Kranker besonders behandelt werden von den Krankenkassen und man versucht, da Kosten zu senken, weil sie weniger zum Arzt gehen sollen. Man versucht also über Callcenter, über, ich will jetzt nicht sagen Hilfsärzte, aber also schon medizinisches mehr oder weniger Fachpersonal, diese Leute beraten zu lassen.
Naja, die nennen sich examierte Pflegekräfte, aber vielmehr, nein nun ja.
Es sind halt keine wirklichen Ärzte. Jedenfalls geht es darum, mit diesen Leuten in Kontakt zu kommen und sie zur Teilnahme an diesem speziellen Programm zu überreden. Das hat jetzt die deutsche Angestelltenkrankenkasse so gemacht, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, wir haben hier irgendwie 200.000 Kunden, die davon potenziell betroffen sind und wir möchten jetzt gern überreden, an diesem Programm teilzunehmen. Dafür haben sie diese Daten an eine externe Firma weitergegeben, mit dem Auftrag, diese Leute anzurufen.
Wollen wir die auch mal ruhig beim Namen nennen? Die heißt nämlich Healthways.
Die haben im Norden von Berlin ein großes Callcenter und ist eine Tochterfirma von einem amerikanischen Unternehmen. Da ist es mit dem Gesundheitssystem ja sowieso ein bisschen sehr viel privatisierter als hier in Deutschland. Da ist was also gang und gäbe. Hier bei uns in Deutschland ist es was Neues. Aber ganz abgesehen von der fachlichen Sache, von der medizinischen Seite her, ist es natürlich ein Problem, wenn eine Krankenversicherung die Bestandsdaten, das sind also Bestandsdaten, nennen sich also diese klassischen Datensätze mit Adresse, Name, Geburtsdatum und so was. Aber eben auch die Tatsache, dass die Kandidaten sind für so ein Chronikerprogramm an eine externe Firma weitergibt, ohne den Versicherten vorher zu fragen. Und das haben die gemacht. Und wie sie sich jetzt hier rauswinden für dieses ganze System, das ist eine ganz interessante Begründung mit Fachbegriffen aus dem Bundesdatenschutzgesetz. Das ist die sogenannte Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag. Und das bedeutet übersetzt, dass ich bin irgendwie ein Diensteanbieter von irgendwas, also ich bin irgendwie eine Firma, kann mir aber kein eigenes Rechenzentrum leisten, weil das ist irgendwie, da braucht man ganz große Computer für und irgendwie einen Internetanschluss und die müssen irgendwo gut abgeschirmt irgendwo im tiefen Keller stehen aus Datenschutzgründen und das könnte ja brennen, was auch immer, Löschanlage und sowas. Deswegen beauftrage ich eine externe Firma, meine Daten zu verarbeiten. Das ist dann die Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag. Das heißt aber eigentlich, also was hier gemacht wurde, ist diese Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag maximal gedehnt dieser Begriff und eigentlich aber auch deutlich überdehnt. Also was nämlich nicht mehr eine Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag ist, dass da jemand sitzt und die Leute anruft. Das ist definitiv keine Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag mehr, sondern Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag meint. Das heißt also, mit diesen Daten automatisiert irgendwas tun. Das heißt, um ein Computersystem zu geben, vielleicht auf Bänder zu speichern, auch möglicherweise mal Briefe automatisiert rauszuschicken. Also klassisch ist es, wenn ich irgendwie meine Kreditkarte oder meine EC-Karte irgendwie neu bekomme, mit einem neuen PIN-Brief oder sowas, dann ist das in der Regel durch einen externen Dienstleister und es ist dann sogenannte Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag.
Okay, das ist jetzt aber sehr tief juristisches, juristische Haarspalterei.
Man kann es einfacher sehen, was haben die da weggegeben von den 200.000?
Genau, aber es gibt unter Strich steht, sie haben Patientendaten an eine externe Firma rausgegeben, ohne dass die Patienten ihre Einwilligung gegeben haben.
Vor allen Dingen, was sind das für Daten? Man muss sich überlegen, es sind nicht nur diese Identifizierungsdaten oder Sozialdaten, sondern auch Leistungsdaten. Das heißt, da stand drin, welche Klinikoffentheite hatten die? Was ist ihnen verordnet worden? Damit hatte diese Firma schon sehr viele, sehr intensiv ausnutzbare Daten. Dazu haben die so eine Betreuungsakte angelegt. Wenn es zu einem telefonischen Kontakt kam, egal ob die erst akquiriert werden sollten oder schon Teilnehmer des Besserlebensprogramms waren, dann haben die natürlich befragt, wie ist ihr Befinden, wie ist ihr derzeitiger Gesundheitszustand. All dieses ging dann in die Betreuungsakte ein. Und das ist ja wohl eine Frechheit, dass vor allen Dingen auch die DRK-Kunden nicht wussten, dass hier ein Dritter für und im Namen der DRK handelt. Und jetzt ist das Programm nicht einstellt worden, sondern seit August ist er erst rausgekommen, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Seit August ist es so, dass die DRK jetzt diesen telefonischen Erstkontakt macht. Aber im Prinzip wird es weiter betrieben, wie bisher, nur dass sie halt vorher sagen, ja sind sie den einverstanden. Auch danach werden wieder die Sozialdaten an diese Firma Healthways rausgegeben und das wird weitergeführt. Eigentlich ist noch was anderes rausgekommen. Das ist zwar ein Modellvorhaben, so ein sogenanntes Management Disease Program, aber das ist durchaus üblich in diesem Gesundheitssektor. Da ist glaube ich noch eine Menge Graubereiche, wo wir hoffen, dass sich ein paar von den Journalisten noch mal ranmachen oder auch einfach nur Bürger oder Whistleblower und sich dann noch mal andere Fälle ansehen, denn andere Krankenkassen werden ähnliche Programme haben.
Also auch das ist zum Stichwort Big Brother Award auch mal eine gute Geschichte, die wir nicht nur verliehen, weil viele Leute Spaß haben, sich auf die Schenkel klopfen und sagen, was es alles für bekloppte Dinge in dieser Welt gibt, sondern auch um eine Aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen, um eine Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen und um Leute sensibel dafür zu machen, wer was mit Daten zum Beispiel treibt. Krankenkasse ist glaube ich neu in diesem Ranking gewesen, zu weit oben. Herzlichen Glückwunsch DAK, ihr habt euch wunderbar daneben genommen. Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 140. Es geht um die Big Brother Awards 2008. Und eure Vorschläge gibt es gerne unter der 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste kommt von Uwe. Guten Abend Uwe. Ey, wie findest du diese Krankenkassennummer?
Ich hab schonmal einen ähnlichen Brief bekommen.
Aber du hast einen anderen Vorschlag.
Die Bürgerämter.
Aha, warum?
Die verkaufen ja Adressdaten, das dürfen sie ja. Aber die machen damit auch so eine Art Raster, weil ein Bekannter hat eine Ausländerin geheiratet und danach einen Umfragebogen bekommen von irgendeiner Uni, wo direkt darauf angespielt wurde, ob er... Naja, Scheinehe, bzw.
auch...
ging eher in die Richtung Unterdrückung, weil ausländische Frauen in Deutschland von ihren Männern halt abhängig sind. Ja, ob er das okay findet, seine Frau zu schlagen, wie viel Sechsualpartner die Frau schon vor ihm hatte.
Ich warte jetzt noch mal. Eine Umfrage von der Uni? Noch mal, damit ich es auch verstehe. Dein Kumpel hat irgendeine Außenneurin geheiratet und einen Post bekommen mit einem Fragebogen, ob er seine Frau schlägt?
Er hat einen bekommen und sie hat einen bekommen.
Aber mal ganz kurz, ist der Brief tatsächlich von dieser Uni abgesendet worden?
Das ist irgendeine Studie im Auftrag von irgendeiner Uni in Berlin.
Aber ist ja der Absender des Briefes, ist das das?
Das ist die Uni, aber er hat recherchiert und herausgefunden, dass seine Adresse über das Bürgeramt an die gekommen ist.
Das heißt, die haben die dann auch bekommen? Also wir geben ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass das Bürgeramt die Briefe für die Uni eintütet und dann rausschickt. Das heißt also, ohne dass die Adressen rausgehen. Das wäre ja auch eine Variante.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist da so eine Rasterung drin, die eigentlich nicht sein dürfte.
Sie haben vorab gefragt, was eventuell die Richtigen sein könnten für ihre Befragung. Das finde ich aber ein ziemliches Ding hier.
Kannst du uns da vielleicht auch noch mal eine Mail schicken an chaosradio.ccc.de? Mit einem kurzen Stichwort, also wie dieser wann es ungefähr war und welches Institut es war. Ich kann wenn möglich diese Fragebögen nochmal. Das wäre auch lustig.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz aufschreiben. Wie ist die Mail?
chaosradio.ccc.de Du tippst, wir können das hören. Muss nicht sofort sein.
Analog, Stift und so.
Super Vorschlag. Ich glaube, da gibt es noch einige Sachen zu entdecken.
Aber sag mal eine Frage noch. Es gab ja eine ganze Menge Datenskandale dieses Jahr. Hast du da so ein bisschen deine Datengewohnheiten auch so ein bisschen verändert?
Ja, ich gucke schon regelmäßig, wo jetzt im Internet was von mir steht. Und pflege das auch. Das muss man schon darauf achten.
Aber bist du denn jetzt wirklich vorsichtiger geworden? Dann noch vorsichtiger vielleicht? Oder sagst du, ich bin eigentlich schon ziemlich vorsichtig?
Na ja, mir geht es schon darum, dass wenn jetzt jemand einfach meinen Namen da in eine Suchmaschine eingibt, dass er jetzt nicht unbedingt sieht, welche Bücher ich kaufe und in welchen Netzwerken ich drinne bin. Da kann man ja mit verschiedenen Synonymen arbeiten.
Und jetzt, wenn du die Datenskandale betrachtest, hast du das manchmal schon satt? Also kannst du dich noch echt aufregen, wenn wieder mal irgendein neuer Datenskandal rauskommt?
Stichwort Universität, Bürgeramt ist ja wohl das beste Beispiel.
Ich meine jetzt mehr so einen großen Skandal. Kriegst du dich da noch auf oder hast du da schon einen gewissen Gewöhnungseffekt?
Na ja, wie soll man sagen? Früher haben sie den Gift einfach irgendwo in einem Wald vergraben und das haben sie jetzt eingelassen. Und jetzt machen sie eine Umweltverschmutzung mit Daten. Also ich denke mal auf eine gewisse Art und Weise wird das schon so bleiben. Und die sozialen Netzwerke, wie vorhin schon, die werden auch noch für ihre Skandale sorgen. Denke ich mal in den nächsten drei Jahren wird da bestimmt einiges passieren. Aber ich sage es mal so, man kann das ein bisschen akzeptieren. Es wird noch eine Menge schiefgehen mit den ganzen Daten.
Wir werden einfach weiterhin mit offenen Augen und Ohren durch die Welt gehen.
Das ist wichtig.
Alles klar. Danke dir, Uwe. Und vergiss nicht, diese Mail zu schicken.
Das klingt spannend.
Alles klar. Bevor wir zum nächsten Teil in die Daten kommen, haben wir noch einen weiteren Anrufer. Und zwar Patrick. Hallo, Patrick. Grüß dich. Guten Tag. Wen hast du auf dem Kika?
Woher wusstet ihr denn jetzt meinen Namen?
Weil du hier die 0331 70 97 110 angerufen hast. Und dann geht der Philipp ans Telefon und sagt, Hallo, hier ist Fritz. Wer ist denn da? Und dann sagst du, Hallo, hier ist Patrick. Und dann schreibt Philipp auf.
Ich hab diesmal meinen Namen nicht genannt.
Offensichtlich doch. Auf jeden Fall hat Philipp mir gesagt, dass du angerufen hast.
22 Jahre alt bist du. Wir wissen alles. Wir kennen deine Vorlieben, die stehen hier in so einem Aufklappfenster.
Und deine Grillpartner. So, Patrick, jetzt mal los.
Ja, sich wird die Metro Gruppe nominieren.
Oh, Firma Saturn, Media Markt, Metro und Co.
Und real. Also, es geht dabei darum, erstmal machen wir natürlich diese ganze Payback-Krempe.
Das machen aber andere auch.
Das machen andere auch, ja. Aber dann zusätzlich fragen sie nach Postleitzahlen, wenn man bezahlt.
Stimmt, aber da muss man ja nicht die sagen, wo man wirklich wohnt.
Ja, man kann 12345 sagen.
Du kannst auch einfach die Postleitzahl von Unterföhring nennen. Ist auch immer schön.
12345 ist auch toll. 12345? Ja, Constanze hat es auch nicht gemerkt.
Hat doch, ich hab's bemerkt.
Aber das ist in der Regel auch das, was dann sozusagen als ungültig, also der Kunde ist nicht bereit, seine Nummer zu geben. Aber du sparst ja halt längliche Diskussionen an der Kasse. 12345 ist mein persönlicher Tipp dabei. Das heißt so viel wie irgendwie du mich auch.
Nee, nee, nee. Also schöner ist zu sagen, nee, und möglichst noch eine Diskussion anzufangen, weil die hinter dir in der Schlange sagen dann auch immer alle nee.
Was ich dann auch noch toll fand, mein Bruder hat dann berichtet, dass wir angefangen haben, irgendwie, ich glaube bei Saturn war es, dann überhaupt gar keine Verkäufer mehr zu haben, alles automatisch und dann kann man nur noch mit EC-Karte und kein Bargeld mehr zahlen oder das Bargeld wird nicht angenommen. Und da hat mein Bruder dann halt die Ware liegen gelassen. Als der Schein nicht angenommen wurde, weil er mit EC-Karte dann nicht bezahlen wollte. Und dann natürlich diese ganze Geschichte bei der Metro, wo sie ja schon testweise angefangen haben mit RFID, dem Kunden halt während der Einkaufen zu verklickern, was wir denn noch so alles kaufen könnten mit ihrem Kaufverhalten.
Das heißt im Grunde ist es so, dass du der Metro Gruppe, wenn man mal zusammenfassen will, vorwürfst, dass ihre neue Digitalstrategie so ein bisschen auf Kosten des Datenschutzes insgesamt geht.
Aber nur leidlich, ist ja nur zu deinem Wohl, damit du weißt, wo die Milch steht.
Also dir passt es mal, glaube ich, generell in die Richtung nicht, oder?
Und dass ich die richtige Produktinformation in meinem Postleitzahlgebiet erhalte.
Wir halten fest, 12 3 45 ist eine gute Postleitzahl, wenn man gefragt wird.
Ich kann mich aber auch beruhigen, die Metro Gruppe hat auch tatsächlich schon einen Preis von uns bekommen. Und zwar für den Future Store und für die Einführung der RFID Technik.
Und die Einführung war sogar hintenrum. Die war ja noch heimlich. Also die haben ja noch so getan, als hätten sie keine. Und dann wurde festgestellt, sie haben halt doch die RFID-Ships in diesem Rheinsberg-Wand, in Rheinsberg im Future Store. Aber eigentlich könnte man doch ruhig noch mal darüber nachdenken. Wir nehmen den Vorschlag mal an.
Wir haben ja auch neun eröffnet.
Zum Thema Unterführung, weil du gerade gefragt hast, Patrick, du kannst natürlich auch irgendwie ein Vorort von München nehmen oder ein kleines Dorf an der holländischen Grenze oder was auch immer, damit die, wenn die ihre Kasse auswerten, plötzlich feststellen, dass Halbholland bei ihnen einkauft. Ist ja auch ganz schön.
Wobei ich sagen muss, insgesamt finde ich Datenerfassung für Kunden ist eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt. Ich arbeite auch in dem Bereich. Ich programmiere und schreibe da auch Datenbanken und Kunden und Interessenten haben wir in unserem Unternehmen. Und wie die Kunden reagieren, dachte ich erst mal, wäre das eine Bevormundung und Spamming. Aber komischerweise ist die Ausbeute riesig. Also wenn jemand eine Anfrage gestellt hat, dann ist das für die offene Erleichterung, wenn die informiert werden, dass das Produkt bald nicht mehr verfügbar ist.
Achso, naja, ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Botschaft sein soll, irgendwie jeder Art von Datensammlung ist böse, sondern natürlich kommt es darauf an, wie das Unternehmen damit umgeht. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel die Daten jetzt in eurem Unternehmen dafür nutzt, irgendwie sinnvolle Dinge, die der Kunde wirklich brauchen kann, mitzuteilen. Etwa, wie bei der Bahn, wenn die Mehrheit nur eine Mehrschrei in der Zug ausfällt, ist das eine andere Sache, als wenn sie meine Daten weiter verkloppen. Das ist glaube ich noch eine Frage, wie man es behandelt. Also ich weiß ja noch nicht, was ihr für einen Geschäftsfeld habt, weil wenn das sinnvolle Informationen sind, wo der Kunde sagt, der Willegeld ist keine bloße Werbung, dann ist das Service, was in der Regel auch das Unternehmen Geld kostet.
Und der Kunde eingewilligt hat.
Ja, wenn der Kunde eingewilligt hat.
Also ich tue in unserem Unternehmen alles, dass unsere Daten sicher sind, dass sie über sichere Verbindungen übertragen werden und dass sie auch wirklich nicht nach außen kommen.
Was machst du denn so?
Wir würden Teufel tun, die zu verkaufen.
Brav, Patrick.
Bitte?
Kannst du umschreiben, was du so in etwa machst?
In etwa, welche Branche?
Oh danke, mehr wollen wir nicht wissen.
Ihr habt ja gerade auch genug zu tun. Danke, Patrick. Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 140. Wir reden über den Big Brother Award 2008 und kommen zum nächsten Nominierten. Und zwar ist das?
Das ist Rolf Gößner, Hattie Laudatio, für diesmal einen Preisträger, der nicht in Deutschland ist, sondern es ist ein EU-Weiterpreis. Und es ist eine Sache, die auch nicht so furchtbar viel Beachtung gefunden hat, die aber für die Leute, die es betrifft, ganz besonders ärgerlich ist. Und, sag ich mal, als mahndes Beispiel stehen sollte für so ähnliche Verfahren. Aber hören wir erst mal rein.
Der EU-Ministerrat erhält den Big Brother Award für die von ihm verantwortete EU-Terrorliste. Darin werden zahlreiche Organisationen und Einzelpersonen als terroristisch eingestuft und gravierenden Sanktionen unterworfen, die zwangsläufig zu schweren Menschenrechtsverletzungen führen. Diese Datensammlung ist weder demokratisch legitimiert, noch unterliegt sie einer demokratischen Kontrolle. Die EU-Terrorliste wird von einem geheimtagenden Gremium des Ministerrates erstellt. Die Entscheidungen erfolgen im Konsens, wobei die für eine Listung vorgebrachten Verdachtsmomente und Indizien zumeist auf dubiosen Geheimdienstinformationen einzelner Mitgliedsstaaten beruhen. Eine unabhängige Beurteilung der Fälle auf Grundlage von gesicherten Beweisen findet jedenfalls nicht statt. Das gesamte Vermögen wird eingefroren, alle Konten und Kreditkarten werden gesperrt, Barmittel beschlagnahmt, Arbeits- und Geschäftsverträge faktisch aufgehoben, weder Arbeitsengeld noch staatliche Sozialleistungen dürfen weiter ausbezahlt werden. Hinzu kommen Passentzug und Ausreisesperre sowie staatliche Überwachungs- und Fahndungsmaßnahmen.
Ja, da muss man sich mal vorstellen, da sitzt dann so ein Gremium und sagt, da haben wir so komische Informationen von unserem Geheimdienst, die haben da irgendwo mal gehört, dass jemand gesagt hätte. Und deswegen setzen wir ihn jetzt mal auf diese Liste. Es reicht zwar nicht, ihn festzunehmen und irgendwie ins Gefängnis zu stecken, aber wir lassen ihn mal ein bisschen schmoren und entziehen ihm mal seinen Pass, sagen ihm bzw. seinem Arbeitgeber, ist dann verpflichtet, ihm seinen Gehalt nicht mehr auszuzahlen. Keine Ahnung, was er kriegt, vielleicht Arbeitslosengeld wird gestrichen. Die Bank sagt, ihr Konto ist jetzt leider gesperrt, an das Geld kommen sie auch nicht mehr ran. Das ist eine Anweisung von ganz oben.
Du kannst auch nichts mehr kaufen, also zum Beispiel Grundstückskauf. Also sind nicht nur die Geldwerte, auch Vermögenswerte, die da beschlagnahmt werden. Das ist eine juristisch richtig heikle Frage, nicht nur bei uns in Deutschland, sondern auch in anderen Juristiktionen. Die Liste gibt es bereits seit Dezember 2001. Das heißt, relativ schnell nach 9-11 ist beschlossen worden, dieses Gremium einzurichten.
Ein geheimtagendes Gremium, hat er auch gerade gesagt. Also man weiß, welche Märkte dazu...
Man weiß, wer drin sitzt, aber eigentlich auch nicht, nach welchen Kriterien. Denn die Regierungen der einzelnen europäischen Staaten schlagen vor, auch die Deutschen natürlich. Und wir haben in Deutschland Fälle, wo versucht wurde seitens der Organisationen oder Personen, die wussten, die sind auf der Liste, dass sie da runterkommen. Es ging hoch bis zum Bundesgerichtshof, aber hat keine durchschlagende Wirkung. Selbst wenn man gerichtlich, also vom BGH ist ja schon eine hohe Instanz, bescheinigt bekommt, dass man keine terroristische Vereinigung ist, sondern wegen Männer nur eine kriminelle oder eben gar nicht kriminelle, da kommt man nicht wieder runter von der Liste. Und angesichts der Tatsache, dass man mal sehen muss, wie Terrorismus in Europa definiert ist, denn wir hatten etwa 2006 498 terroristische Anschläge nach der Definition der EU, was natürlich für den normalen Menschen unverstehbar ist, dann sieht man, wie leicht man dort zum Terroristen wird. Das ist eine ganz kritische Sache. Es ist vor allen Dingen überhaupt nicht überprüfbar. Die Liste wird immer länger und länger. Jedes halbe Jahr Minimum wird die abgedatet. Niemand weiß, wie man da wieder runterkommt.
Das ist auch hier ganz wichtig. Big Brother Award für den EU-Ministerrat, für die Terrorliste, mit dem Hintergrund, möglichst viele Leute über das Existenzieren dieser Liste und über die Umstände und die Konsequenzen zu informieren, damit viele Leute darüber nachdenken. Mein Vorschlag ist, wir hören jetzt einen Song zum Thema und reden danach mit Stefan, der hat noch mal Vodafone auf dem Kika und dann machen wir weiter mit dem Big Brother Award 2008. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich sie alle sehen kann. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich sie alle sehen kann. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich sie alle sehen kann.
Vodafone ist insofern suspekt, als dass ich vor circa einem Monat Anrufe bekommen habe von unbekannten Teilnehmern. Und da gehe ich eigentlich grundsätzlich nicht dran. Das ist dann so 8 Uhr morgens bis 10 Uhr abends, fünfmal am Tag. Zwischendurch kommen dann Anrufe plus 490 und ab und an auch mal dann wirklich eine ganze Nummer. Und einmal bin ich dann auch wirklich drangegangen und hatte dann den Service von Vodafone an der Leitung. Ja, nicht zwangsläufig. Sicherlich wollte er dann auch wissen, was er dann noch für mich tun kann, aber er beteuerte dann, dass der Computer bei denen spinnen würde. Aber das Einzige, was ich damals gehört habe, ist quasi der Hintergrund von einem Callcenter. So als wenn man dem Computer irgendwie ein Headset aufgesetzt hätte und der würde dann den Background-Noise aus dem Callcenter übermitteln.
Viele Leute werden kennen oder wissen, wie sich das anhört, das kennen ja viele.
Das klingt aber erstmal so wie so ein bisschen so eine Belästigung. Also ich meine, durch einen wild gewordenen Callcenter-Computer oder sowas.
Was wollten die denn jetzt konkret von dir?
Im Grunde gar nichts. Ich bin wirklich einmal drangegangen und...
Die wollten dich einfach nochmal anrufen? Die haben kein besonderes... Also die haben nicht gesagt, sie wollen diese Doreenet kaufen oder können wir ihnen diese Doreenet vielleicht noch... Nix? So?
Nein.
Und die haben mal Hallo gesagt, wie geht's ihnen heute?
Wahrscheinlich war das auch ein Test von den...
Und wo wir sie schon mal an der Struppe haben, was können wir noch für sie tun?
Auflegen.
Also ich glaube, da hätte ich mich ja noch viel mehr belästigt gefühlt, als wenn irgendwer mir was verkloppen würde, dann kann man ja gleich auflegen, wenn die noch so Hallo sagen und so. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich reagiert hätte.
Also wie gesagt, diese Nummer erschien im Display und die habe ich dann mal zurückgerufen und dann meldete sich dieser nette Herr und was denn mein Anliegen wäre und hab das dann geäußert, dass ich mich also inzwischen wirklich belästigt fühle, weil ich sag mal so fünf bis zehn Anrufe am Tag von unbekannten Teilnehmern, dieser plus 490 Nummer, die ja eigentlich ungewöhnlich ist und auch dieser Vodafone-Nummer, ja ich fühlte mich schon irgendwo belästigt.
Kann es eventuell was damit zu tun haben, dass dein Telefon sich denn in Holland eingebucht hatte?
Nein, nein.
Also da habe ich die automatische Netzwahl ausgeschaltet und ist also wirklich nur auf deutsches Vodafone-Netz eingestellt.
Na, unterm Strich, unterm Strich fällt das Unternehmen Vodafone dieser Sendung schon zum zweiten Mal.
Na gut, für ein Big Brother Award wird das wohl nicht genügen, aber wir haben ja Vodafone ohnehin schon, als man mal notiert, ich weiß nicht, sowas würde mich auch nerven, kann ich verstehen, ich sehe das aber nicht als irgendwie Daten-Kragen-Oscar-Wert.
Aber es ist schon sehr suspekt, dass man an das Telefon geht und man hört einfach nichts. Man versucht dann irgendwo über Hallo und wer ist denn da und so Kontakt herzustellen, aber man hört einfach nichts.
Das klingt aber echt so ein bisschen wie ein wildgewordener Callcenter-Computer.
Ja, was auch immer. Und im Zweifel, wenn sie anrufen und fragen, was sie für dich tun können, dann sagst du, ob sie nicht die Durchwahl von einem anderen Mobilfunkanbieter für dich hätten. Danke Stefan.
Gute Nacht, tschau.
Manchmal kommt neue Musik nicht aus den Charts, sondern aus den Kellern von São Paulo. Mittwoch, 12. November, in der Maria am Ufer in Berlin-Priedrichshain. Neue Musik aus Brasilien. Nachrichten mit Philipp Berger.
Der Zeitplan für die Berliner Umweltzone soll eingehalten werden. Darauf besteht Umweltsenatorin Lombscher von der Linken trotz Kritik. Danach dürfen ab 2010 Fahrzeuge mit roter und gelber Plakette nicht mehr in die Innenstadt fahren. Die Grünen stehen hinter dem Termin, fordern aber Kredite zum Umrüsten alter Fahrzeuge. Die CDU und Teile der SPD verlangen eine Verschiebung der Pläne um zwei Jahre. Die EU-Kommission will die europäische Autoindustrie unterstützen. Zinsgünstige Kredite für die Produktion umweltschonender Motoren sollen den Autobauern helfen, wieder mehr Fahrzeuge verkaufen zu können. Verhandelt wird über eine Gesamtkredithöhe von rund 40 Milliarden Euro. Währenddessen haben nach der Hypo Real Estate weitere große Privatbanken beschlossen, das Hilfspaket der Bundesregierung doch zu nutzen. Darunter die Deutsche, die Commerz, die Dresdner und die Postbank. Die Krankenkassenbeiträge für gesetzlich Versicherte steigen im kommenden Jahr auf ein Rekordniveau. Das Bundeskabinett hat einen einheitlichen Beitragssatz von 15, 5 Prozent vom Bruttolohn beschlossen. Im Schnittzahlen gesetzlich Versicherte damit gut 100 Euro mehr im Jahr. Gesundheitsministerin Schmidt sagte, das sei der letzte Schritt zur Einführung des Gesundheitsfonds zum 1. Januar 2009. Der Flughafen Tempelhof wird morgen endgültig geschlossen. Nach 85 Jahren soll der Flugbetrieb um Mitternacht enden. Zuvor sollen noch einmal zwei historische Maschinen von der Stadtbahn abheben. Ein sogenannter Rosinenbomber und eine Tante Yu. Was aus dem einst größten Gebäude der Welt und dem riesigen Flughafenfeld wird, ist noch ungewiss. Kritiker der Schließung wollen morgen mit einer Lichterkette vor dem Flughafeneingang protestieren. Start. In der Fußballbundesliga hat Hertha BSC am Abend gegen Hannover mit 3 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Berliner stehen nach diesem Sieg mit 18 Punkten auf dem fünften Tabellenplatz. Spitzenreiter ist wieder Aufsteger Hoffenheim nach einem 3 zu 1 Erfolg in Bochum. Die weiteren Ergebnisse. Frankfurt verliert gegen Bayern München 1 zu 2. Köln unterliegt Dortmund 0 zu 1. Und Hamburg besiegt Stuttgart 2 zu 0. Die Nacht ist stark bewirkt in Berlin und Brandenburg. Vor allem im Südosten kann es regnen. Morgen bleibt es weiterhin stark bewirkt, regnerisch. Es kann auch Schnee regnen. Am Nachmittag soll es dann aber ein bisschen auflockern und weniger regnen. Kühl wird es morgen mit Temperaturen zwischen 2 und maximal 7 Grad. Und aktuell sind es in Frankfurt 6 Grad, in Potsdam-Angermünde und Berlin 5, in Neuropin und Cottbus 4 Grad und in Wittenberge 1 Grad. A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen den Ausfahrten Brandenburg an der Havel und Netzen ist wegen Bauarbeiten die rechte Spur gesperrt. Bundesstraße 96, Luckau Richtung Hoyerswerda. Zwischen Finsterwalde und der Einmündung Großreschen ist die Bundesstraße wegen eines abgestellten Schwerlastertransports voll gesperrt. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111 statt auswärts Richtung Oranienburg. Zwischen Dreieck Charlottenburg und Heckerdam ist die linke Spur gesperrt. A113 statt auswärts Richtung Schönefeld. Zwischen Spätstraße und Stubenrauchstraße sind die linke und die mittlere Spur gesperrt. Und wegen Wartungsarbeiten kommt es heute Nacht auch zu vereinzelten Spursperrungen auf dem Stadtring der A100. Bitte achtet auf die Beschilderung. Gute Fahrt.
Danke.
Und dann im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Warum bloggen wir?
Gute Frage, stellt sich. Die Welt ist scheiße. Es herrschen Kriege, Hunger, Elend und Mordall überall. Die Welt ist scheiße. Ws sind schuld. Klechten, foltern und ermorden uns. Wir blonzen sie weg von hier. Wir blonzen sie sehr nenten raus. Wir blonzen sie weg von hier. Wir blonzen sie sehr nenten raus. Es herrschen Kriege, Hunger, Elend und Mordel überall. Und wir schreiben, reden und sagen es. Denn wir halten nicht unser Maul. Wir blonzen sie weg von hier. Wir blonzen sie im Empte raus. Irgendwo anders hin. Wir blonzen sie weg von hier. Wir blonzen sie weg von hier. Irgendwo anders hin. Die Welt ist scheiße. Das Nu, Spreeblick, Bildblog, X der Wirre, MC Winkel, Thomas Knüger und das Loreblog, Jens Scholtz, Masa Models, Anki Gröner und die Werbeblogger.
www.diewelt-is-scheiße.de Das Bloggerlied habt ihr gerade gehört. Wir haben gerade festgestellt im Chaos Computer Club, im Chaos Radio Fritz, dass die Nummer zwar ulkig ist, aber noch nicht so richtig reicht, um sie zu skandieren oder um da jetzt irgendwie einen super Hit draus zu machen. Also vielleicht fühlt sich einer von euch bemüßigt, da mal einen aktuell schmissigen Remix draufzukleben. www.deweltdescheiß.de da kann man den auf jeden Fall hören.
Wir haben eigentlich nur gespielt, weil wir da Hörer haben, die den Song so gerne mögen, ich glaube, das war jetzt das letzte Mal, oder?
Eins von dem ist doch hier im Studio, du findest den auch toll, Konz? Jaaa, wir haben auch wenig Zeit, wir müssen es gar nicht ausweiten. Chaos Radio Fritz, Nummer 140, es geht um die Big Brother Awards 2008. Falls ihr jetzt erst zugeschaltet habt, wir hatten schon den EU-Ministerrat für Terrorliste, wir hatten die DAK, die Krankenkasse für die Weitergabe von Patientendaten an eine Privatfirma. Wir hatten schon die Telekom, wir hatten schon den Arbeitskreis Deutscher Markt- und Sozialforschungsinstitute, weil sie Gespräche aufzeichnen und auswerten, obwohl die gar nicht aufgezeichnet und ausgewertet werden sollen. Und der nächste im Bund ist ein Stromanbieter.
Genau, das ist die Firma YellowStrom und die machen, wie viele andere auch, neue Projekte zur elektronischen Erfassung des Stromverbrauchs. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt in der Laudatio kommt, deswegen kurz vorweg. Es gibt tatsächlich auch ein Gesetz, was am Hintergrund ist, oder ein Gesetzesvorhaben, was das Ganze angestoßen hat, nämlich, dass die Stromanbieter in Zukunft verpflichtet werden, noch genauer, nämlich mindestens monatlich, eine Zusammenstellung zu geben, also den Stromverbrauch übermitteln zu können. Die Idee ist, dass die Verbraucher besser einschätzen können, welche Geräte wie viel Strom verbrauchen, wie viel Strom sie überhaupt verbrauchen, um ihr Verhalten entsprechend einschätzen zu können.
Also, dass dir niemand sagen kann, meine Strommaschine zu hoch ist, du hast aber auch eine alte Waschmaschine.
Genau, das ist die Idee davon. Man kann das Ganze jetzt noch sehr viel weiter treiben. Es geht darum, auch den Stromverbrauch, sage ich mal, je nach Belastung des Stromnetzes, also was die anderen so verbrauchen, das ist wie eine Börse. Also wenn ganz viel Strom verbraucht wird, dann wird der Strom teuer. Und in sogenannten Spitzenzeiten und Zeiten, wo weniger Strom verbraucht, wird der Strom billiger. Das heißt, ich kann mir überlegen, ob ich die Waschmaschine denn vielleicht zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt anlaufe.
Das klingt bis jetzt alles noch sehr vernünftig.
Klingt bis jetzt alles ganz vernünftig. So ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben hat es jetzt Yellow Strom mit dem sogenannten Sparzähler, der auch tatsächlich schon oder ab demnächst vertrieben wird, der aber jetzt schon mal angekündigt ist. Wo also, ja, hören wir mal rein einfach.
Der Big Brother Award 2008 in der Kategorie Technik geht an die Yellow Strom GmbH. Vertreten durch ihren Geschäftsführer Martin Vespa. Es war für die Vorreiterrolle bei der Einführung der Digital Stromtechnik für Privatkunden und zwar ohne jegliche Informationen zum Datenschutz der Kunden. Digital Stromtechnik ermöglicht eine sekundengenau Erfassung des Stromverbrauchs einer Wohnung, ja sogar einzelner Geräte. Und damit könnte in sie in Zukunft zur detaillierten Überwachung aller Aktivitäten im häuslichen Bereich genutzt werden. Doch was ist nun eigentlich das Problem? Ganz einfach, eine detailreiche Verbrauchsmessung gibt sehr viele Informationen über die Verbraucherpreis. Wann wird aufgestanden? Wann aus dem Haus gegangen? Wann wird gekocht? Wann wird Fernsehen geschaut? Sind die Bewohner etwa verreist? Wenn zusätzlich auch noch Gas- und Wasserverbrauch gemessen werden, können noch leichter Mutmaßungen darüber angestellt werden, wie viele Personen sich gerade in der Wohnung befinden. Und vieles mehr.
Aber das sind natürlich Daten, die erhoben werden können über diesen Zähler. Aber ist das denn Absicht gewesen von Jellostrom, ich frage dich jetzt ganz bewusst so naiv, ist es denn Absicht gewesen von Jellostrom, solche Daten über die Kunden zu erheben, um diese Daten zu erheben, ihnen diesen Zähler unterzuschieben? Oder ist das jetzt eher ein Nebenprodukt?
Die Idee ist, dass die Kunden tatsächlich auch mit Zusatzsteckern, also Zwischensteckern, ihre Geräte einzeln überprüfen können. Es gibt dazu noch einen kleinen speziellen Chip, der von der ETH Zürich entwickelt worden ist, unter der sogenannten Digitalstrominitiative, dass sogar neu produzierte Geräte einen kleinen Chip drin haben, der diesen Stromverbrauch, den aktuellen Stromverbrauch des Gerätes, dann an den häuslichen Stromzähler übermittelt. Dazu haben die dann auch eine weltweit eindeutige ID. Das heißt also, jeder Stromverbrauch von jedem Gerät kann von diesem Stromzähler dann, der zu Hause hängt, zugeordnet werden. Das Problem ist, dass dieser Stromzähler, das ist dann irgendwie ein kleiner Computer, den muss man sich so vorstellen wie so ein DSL Modem, der wird dann auch tatsächlich ans Internet angeschlossen. Die Frage ist, wer kommt auf dieses Gerät drauf? Also, habe ich den unter Kontrolle oder hat Yellow Strom den unter Kontrolle? Und unsere große Sorge nebenbei ist, dass natürlich dann die Stromanbieter aufgrund von irgendwelchen Antiterror-Gesetzen möglicherweise auch dazu verpflichtet werden, und das wird auch ganz sicher passieren, auch den Behörden entsprechend Auskunft zu geben, wie es denn gerade so in dieser Wohnung so geschieht. Also, das heißt, wie viele Personen sind da möglicherweise? Sind möglicherweise neue Personen hinzugekommen? Steigt der Stromverbrauch? Wird also länger abends Fernsehen gesehen? Es gibt da ziemlich einen Auffluss darüber, über die Lebensgewohnheiten von jemand. Und wenn man das sekundengenau macht und auch wirklich anhand des Stromverbrauchs diese Geräte einzeln identifizieren kann, ist das schon eine ganz erhebliche Überwachungsmöglichkeit.
Also auch dieser Preis an Yellow Strom zu Recht, wir applaudieren nicht, aber wünschen trotzdem gutes Gelingen. Wir haben noch einen Anruf, 0331 70 97 110. Axel ist am Telefon, Namd. Und auch ein ganz beliebter Kandidat für den Big Brother Award, kommt von dir.
Ja, also erstmal noch ganz kurz zu Yellow. Was fällt mir als erstes ein? Es wird Zeit, dass man wieder Netzfilter einbaut, oder?
Also kleine Zwischengeräte, die da...
Ich meine, solange die Irren sowieso schon auf die Idee kommen über die Stromleitung irgendwelche hochfrequenten Signale schicken zu wollen, die ich mit viel Mühe versuche, aus meiner Stellanlage rauszuhalten, muss ich sowieso schon drüber nachdenken, muss ich einfach bloß noch mehr davon einbauen.
Na ja, die Möglichkeiten für zivilen Widerstandwände sicherlich noch alle durchdacht werden.
Auch das ein Thema für eine der kommenden Sendungen.
Ja, ganz spannend. Aber jetzt zum Big Brother Award zurück, wie wäre es mit den Kollegen von Lidl?
Ah, die Kollegen, die ihre Mitarbeiter...
Die ihre Mitarbeiter per Mitarbeiter Lidl. was sie alles tun und lassen und das doch alles nur zum Wohle.
Ja, natürlich. Und dass sie auch die Angaben, wenn sie eingestellt werden, machen müssen.
Genau.
Dass sie nicht so viel mit ihren Kollegen reden. Warten die noch so, dass sie in Tschechien rote Bänder tragen müssen?
Ja, nee, es war auch bei Lidl Frauen, Mitarbeiterinnen, die ihre Tage haben mussten, das kennzeichnen, weil sie ja öfter als die anderen zur Toilette gehen müssen. Aber die haben schon einen Preis bekommen, Frank, ne?
Richtig, die waren, in den vergangenen Jahren waren die schon Preisempfänger. Ja, die haben wir schon sehr früh damit gedacht. Ich glaube, ich muss lügen, das war vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich. Und die genau, also die, nämlich genau für diese ganze Geschichte, also alles, was jetzt durch die Presse, durch die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist, war schon Teil dieses Preises damals. Und auch über uns, also auch die gleichen Sachen, also wir haben auch wirklich das gleiche Recherchematerial gehabt, was jetzt für die große Berichterstattung, also es ist so wie komisch, dass es zwei Jahre gedauert hat, aber wir waren zuerst da. Immerhin, Lidl hat auch dieses Jahr von sich aus schon angefragt, wie sieht es aus, sollen wir jemanden schicken kriegen, den Preis, müssen wir sie leider enttäuschen? Nein, hatte das schon vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder später.
Ah ja, gut, zweite Idee, die ist aber auch nicht ganz neu. Das sind die Erfinder der elektronischen Krankenkarten. Krankenkassenkarten.
Der Klassiker.
Damit tun wir uns sehr, sehr schwer ganz kurz, weil es eigentlich noch nicht so viel Greifbares gibt. Also die ganze Sache ist noch sehr in Bewegung. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die sind zumindest heikel. Es sind ein paar Sachen, die sind aber auch so gut gelöst, wie man es zumindest technisch machen kann nach dem derzeitigen Stand der Wissenschaft und Technik. Ob man die Gesundheitskarte jetzt insgesamt gut oder schlecht finden soll, ist glaube ich eine komplexe Diskussion. Kann man jetzt ja auch nicht einzeln mal leutern. Aber wir haben es noch nicht so richtig, konnten uns noch nicht richtig durchringen, einfach weil noch so viel in Bewegung ist. Wenn sowas immer noch in Bewegung ist, dann geben wir natürlich den Firmen oder den Organisationen immer noch die Chance sagen, naja, wir haben es jetzt ganz anders gemacht. Der Preis ist ja gar nicht mehr gültig.
Ich glaube wir machen mal eine zukünftige Liste und setzen die elektronische Gesundheitskarte mal schon drauf. Sie können es ja noch verkacken.
Genau.
Wir können es als Vorschlag durchaus annehmen. Vielleicht nicht gleich für nächste. Wir warten erst mal, bis sie es umgesetzt haben und der erste Daten-GAU passiert ist.
Aber ein relativ ähnlicher Kandidat hat ja die Kategorie Politik gewonnen.
Die Kategorie Politik war auf jeden Fall noch ein Preis. Ich hab nämlich die ganzen Kategorien so ein bisschen. Du spielst jetzt eine auf Elena. Wahrscheinlich das Elena-Verfahren ist der sogenannte elektronisch-Einkommensnachweis. Und ist eine Sache, die auch recht wenig in der Öffentlichkeit war. Es geht darum, dass alle Arbeitgeber, also alle Firmen, wo die Leute beschäftigt sind, müssen in Zukunft monatlich eine Gehaltsbescheinigung, also einen Einkommensnachweis an eine sogenannte zentrale Speicherstelle übermitteln. Die Idee ist, dass wenn ich irgendwann Arbeitslosengeld, Erziehungsgeld oder irgendwas beantrage, auch Wohngeld, muss ich bisher immer zu meinem Arbeitgeber gehen und mir einen Gehaltsnachweis ausstellen lassen, dass die wissen, also für alle staatlichen Leistungen, die entsprechend meinem Gehalt des letzten Jahres berechnet werden, die Höhe der Unterstützung berechnet wird. Dafür bräuchten sogenannten Gehaltsnachweis. Das Ganze soll in Zukunft elektronisch gemacht werden. Dafür müssen die Arbeitgeber alle diese Daten, die ganzen Einkommensdaten, meine Anschrift, Geburtsdatum, die Höhe der Bezüge, alles an eine zentrale Speicherstelle übermitteln. Das ist also eine riesige große Datenbank, wo das dann alles für ein Jahr gespeichert wird. Egal, ob ich jetzt irgendwann mal mich arbeitslos melde oder irgendwie hier Gelder beantrage, erstmal alles in die Datenbank rein und wir gucken mal, was wir davon wieder brauchen. Also im Prinzip eine riesige Datensammlung auf Vorrat.
Na vielleicht, wenn sich welche noch erinnern. Früher hieß das mal JobCard. Die haben es unterdessen mal umbenannt. Nur falls jemand mal über die JobCard gelesen hat, ist es dasselbe wie Eleanor.
Richtig. Wir haben noch quasi einen zweiten Teil des Preises. Das ist nämlich die sogenannte Karte, diese Zugangskarte zu staatlichen Leistungen. Das ist also das, was früher JobCard heißt. Die heißt jetzt nicht mehr ganz so, sondern ist im Prinzip eine Signaturkarte. Und da haben wir insgesamt Signaturverfahren auch als solche, sagen wir mal, als kritisch eingestuft, weil man nämlich mit jeder elektronischen Unterschrift, die man macht, das ist also ein Verfahren, was für die meisten von euch erst noch in der Zukunft ist. Aber wer zum Beispiel eine Steuererklärung schon abgeben will oder wer Anwalt ist, kennt es möglicherweise schon. Es gibt elektronische Gerichtspost. Man kann die also elektronisch unterschreiben. Bei dieser elektronischen Unterschrift wird aber auch immer die Zertifikatsidentifikationsnummer, sprich wie eine Seriennummer meiner Chipkarte, mit mit dieser elektronischen Unterschrift gespeichert. Das heißt, ich kann also zentral erfassen, welche Dokumente ich jemals in meinem Leben mit dieser Karte unterschrieben hab. Und das ist nochmal so ein kleiner, ungünstiger Nebeneffekt von dieser Sache.
So ein winziger kleiner.
Der jetzt extrem technisch, ich sag mal, sehr anspruchsvoll ist, aber wo es wichtig ist, mal gehört zu haben davon und wer so Lust hat, sich da nochmal ein bisschen näher einzulesen, da gibt es auch schon ein bisschen was zum Thema elektronische Signatur und eben diesem Nebeneffekt dieser Zertifikats-ID.
Also wir werden vor allen Dingen, weil wir vorhin ganz am Anfang der Sendung über die Steuer-ID gesprochen haben, wir haben hier eine ähnliche Problematik eigentlich. Vor allen Dingen ist es auch hier wieder so formuliert, dass sie so eine sogenannte Öffnungsklausel haben. Sprich, dass eigentlich jetzt schon klar ist, dass diese Daten auch zweitverwertet werden, etwa von Sozialämtern und so weiter. Also hier ist wieder mal vom Gesetzgeber ziemlich am Rucks gemacht worden. Das wird sich ja nicht wieder bei den Gerichten nennen.
Immerhin gab es schon ein bisschen Diskussionen, auch im Bundestag, man hat nochmal darüber diskutiert, hat gemerkt, dass es vielleicht doch nicht so eine ganz glorreiche Idee ist.
Verdanken wir übrigens noch der rot-grünen Bundesregierung, um das auch mal zu betonen.
Genau, es ist keine neue Sache, sondern wird schon seit 2002 geplant. Da kommt auch dieser Name JobCard her. Das Verfahren hat sich jetzt schon noch um einiges gewandelt. Unbedingt datenschutzfreundlicher ist es aber nicht geworden.
Womit in der großen Liste der Big Brother Awards 2008?
Noch einer übrig ist, wolltest du sagen?
Noch einer übrig ist, weil wir haben echt, wir haben noch einen Haufen Anrufer, aber es tut uns echt leid.
Ja, es ist immer so schade, wir würden gerne noch mehr Anrufer rein.
Wir würden gerne noch mehr Leute, aber es ist, uns läuft die Zeit weg, je länger wir schnattern, weil vor der Tür stehen schon Robert Smith und Maxwell, die hier mit dem Night Flight kommen, die wollen ja auch pünktlich ihren Dienst beginnen.
Ich glaube auch, dass man Fritz die Zeit schneller vergeht.
Ja, genau, das liegt an den Erdstrahlen, die hier sind. Nein, wir haben noch einen letzten übrig und zwar, wer ist noch?
Ach so, Bundestag. Genau, an die Mitglieder des Bundestages für das Schnelldurchwinken.
Haben wir da eine Laudatio?
Da haben wir, das ist die drei.
Wollen wir vorher noch sagen, worum es geht?
Also genau, es geht um Reisegesetze. Reisegesetze sind ein bisschen zu umgangssprachlich. Es geht um Gesetze, die das Reisen insgesamt beeinflussen, beeinträchtigen oder betreffen. Es geht dabei vor allem um Schiffsreisen und um Flugreisen.
Schiffsreisen, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Der Big Brother Award in der Kategorie Verbraucher geht 2008 an die Mitglieder des 16. Deutschen Bundestages, vertreten durch Dr. Norbert Lammert, Präsident des Deutschen Bundestages, für das Durchwinken mehrerer Gesetze, die eine Erhebung, langfristige Speicherung und Weitergabe von detaillierten Daten über Reisende erzwingen. Wussten Sie zum Beispiel, dass künftig die Daten von Passagieren und Fährschiffen und Kreuzfahrtschiffen automatisch an die Schifffahrtsbehörden und an die Bundespolizei übermittelt, dort gespeichert und sogar an andere Behörden und Unternehmen weitergereicht werden? Ihr Ausflug auf die ostfriesischen Inseln wird in Zukunft also registriert. Dies haben wir einem Gesetz zu verdanken, das am 24. Januar 2008 vom Bundestag mit nur wenigen Gegenstimmen von der Öffentlichkeit quasi unbemerkt durchgewunken wurde. Es hat den sperrigen Namen Gesetz zur Änderung seeverkehrsrechtlicher, verkehrsrechtlicher und anderer Vorschriften mit Bezug zum Seerecht. Was vielleicht darauf hindeutet, dass unsere Volksvertreter sich nicht so genau damit beschäftigt haben. Neu ist unter anderem der Paragraph 9e im Seeaufgabengesetz, worin die über jeden Reisenden zu speichernden Daten aufgelistet werden. Zur Gefahrenabwehr, versteht sich. Darunter Name, Ausweisnummer sowie Abfahrts- und Ankunftshafen. Diese Daten dürfen an nicht näher spezifizierte öffentliche Stellen übermittelt werden. Außerdem, falls nötig, an Hafenbetriebe, Schiffsmeldestellen, Hafendienstleister und andere nicht öffentliche Stellen, sprich private Firmen. Sogar der Transfer an ausländische und über- oder zwischenstaatliche öffentliche Stellen, wie es so schön heißt, ist mit wenigen schwammigen Ausnahmen erlaubt.
Das heißt, ich mach einen kleinen Ausflug auf die ausfriesischen Inseln, wie es gerade eben erwähnt wurde, da sült oder wohin auch immer und zack bin ich in einer Datenbank.
Genau, in mindestens einer sogar.
Schöne neue Welt.
Da haben sie den echt mal wieder verdient. Also ich meine, im Bundestag, also immer der jeweilige Chef sozusagen, hier der Lammert, die haben es ja schon öfter mal gekriegt, aber hier lohnt sich's wirklich. Es ist wieder so ein typischer, irgend so ein komischer Ausschuss, wo nie einer mal vorbeiguckt. Irgendwann sehrecht mei es.
Wobei, also was natürlich auch Teil des Preises war, das haben wir jetzt noch nicht gehört, natürlich die ganze Fluggastdatenübermittlung. Die ist auch ein Teil davon und die ist ja jetzt, es gibt jetzt ein offizielles Gesetz dazu, dann offiziell Übereinkunft, wobei die Übermittlung jetzt eigentlich noch schlimmer ist als zu der Wedenzeit vorher, wo es also keine ordentliche Regelung dazu gab. Man hat das also jetzt nochmal alles eigentlich viel, viel schlimmer gemacht. Und dieser fluggeharzte Datenaustausch ist natürlich der absolute Datenhorror. Kann man nicht anders sagen. Der war auch Teil des Preises.
Das waren die Big Brother Awards 2008. Auch dank eurer Beteiligung gibt es noch einige Vorschläge, die möglicherweise für 2009 dann berücksichtigt werden. Wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, BigBrotherAwards.de oder aber ihr klickt auf die Website zur Sendung Chaosradio.ccc.de Da gibt es auch den Podcast nochmal zum Inruhen nachhören. Und wenn ihr mehr 19 Zoll Gespräche hören wollt, dann bleibt einfach da, weil dann gibt es das Chaos Radio Express. Und da ist ein bisschen mehr Technik, als wir es heute in der Sendung hatten. Wir machen uns jetzt vom Acker, hier geht es weiter mit dem Night Flight, mit Maxwell und mit Robert Smith. Haben wir noch irgendwas?
Ja, ich glaube so, weil wir haben wieder einen Datengarten im Berliner Chaos Computer Club. Aber weil wir jetzt keine Zeit mehr haben, müsst ihr auf die Webseiten klicken und euch informieren.
Und wir wollen natürlich auch schon mal ganz langsam und rechtzeitig auf unseren Chaos Communication Kongress hinweisen. Unsere jährliche Veranstaltung findet wieder statt zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr.
27. bis 30. und ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass nach diesem Wochenende schon der Fahrplan stehen wird.
Und wenn nicht kommt, schicken Sie einen Entschuldigungszettel von Motiv. Danke, dass ihr da wart. Constanze Fragrosengard, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Danke fürs Zuhören im Chaosradio. Bis denn, tschüss. Tschüss.